Hallo!
Chaos Communication Congress und das ist voll. Wir begrüßen euch. Hallo! Willkommen zur Freak Show.
Wir fordern den Rücktritt der Freak Show europaweit und teilt dieses Video. Teilt es! Nur ein einziges Mal hört auf mich, teilt dieses Video. Haben wir nicht schon genug gesehen? Haben wir die Stanzen nicht endgültig voll von dieser Freak Show? Ich wiederhole nochmal. Wir fordern den Rücktritt der Freak Show. Und für die Leute, die es nicht kapieren wollen, ihr sollt zurücktreten. Wir brauchen euch nicht mehr. Und das iOS brauchen wir auch nicht. Wir verlangen ein neues iOS-System auch noch, weil das bisherige ist total kacke. Ich bin dankbar dafür, dass ihr dieses Video teilt. Wer meiner Meinung ist, teilt es einfach.
Den von Starbucks.
Den von Starbucks habe ich noch nicht gesehen, der ist sicherlich auch toll, aber habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Nein, nein, das ist von dem, wie hieß der Vogel, Daniel irgendwas? Nee, David, David irgendwas. Und der hat ja durch Zufall herausgefunden, dass diese Xerox-Scanner, diese, wie heißt man mal, diese Serie, Work, ach Gott, ich krasse gerade nicht, also Industrie-Scanner, teure Scheiße sozusagen, die auch in allen großen Firmen drin ist, dass die einfach mal ihre Image-
Compression so verkackt haben, dass sie die Bechstaben verwuchseln.
Dass sie die Bechstaben verwuchseln. Also kurz gesagt, diese ganze Hang zum kleiner machen und so weiter führt dann dazu, dass sie sozusagen so Blöcke erkennen, so einzelne Bereiche isolieren, unter anderem dann halt auch einzelne Buchstaben und dann dadurch optimieren, dass etwas, was irgendwie sehr ähnlich aussieht, dann nehmen sie dann den selben Index.
Genau, das mag man für Scanner haben. Und dann haben sie halt... Kann aber auch ein A sein, scheiß drauf.
Aus vielen Sechsen sind da achten geworden und so. Und dann hat er halt diese ganze Story auch erzählt. Das ist nicht nur interessant, hier ist aus dem technischen Aspekt, das war ihm sehr interessant und auch hervorragend und sehr, sehr unterhaltsam wiedergegeben worden, wie dieser ganze Verlauf war, diese Kommunikation zwischen ihm und Xerox und wie sich das so langsam entwickelte und welche Fehler er auch alle bewusst vermieden hat, was sich dann am Ende auch als sehr positiv herausgestellt hat, im Umgang mit dieser ganzen Geschichte. Die kurze Story ist halt einfach, das ist der totale Megafail und seit acht Jahren, seit acht Jahren scannen die einfach Scheiße.
Also was heißt scannen, auch wenn ich jetzt schon ein Blatt drauflege und mir eine Kopie haben will, dann ist das auch schon falsch.
Weil sie das scannen und wieder ausdrucken.
Das heißt, ne, das stimmt nicht, das wurde ja auch gefragt, ich glaube da hat er nicht so hundertprozentig, da wurden diese Kompressionsalgorithmen nicht aktiviert. Aber es gab halt schon so besorgte Anrufe von so Stadtarchiven und so, die halt irgendwie erzählt haben, dass die die Originale dann halt weggeschmissen, weil die waren ja gescannt. Ja, die haben so richtig Sackgang. Der Talk ist einfach ein sehr schönes Ding für, schöne Beispiele für die, wie man es nicht macht. Ja, aber auch für die Atmo auf dem Kongress, also die Begeisterung der Zuschauer und so weiter, da hat irgendwie alles gestimmt. Ich kann bestimmt noch ein paar andere Sachen empfehlen.
Ja, jeder darf einen Talk empfehlen, würde ich sagen. Das ist die Guideline.
Hab ich jetzt gemacht.
Du hast deinen verbraucht.
Genau, wir müssen jetzt was anderes einfallen lassen. Wir können ja, bevor wir weitere Talks empfehlen, nochmal kurz hier auf das Vogue-Thema zurückschwenken, weil da gibt's ja noch einiges zu holen. Was ja auch...
Mach mal den Tabak zu, der wird so trocken.
Was dazukam, Subtitling war ja so ein Projekt, was letztes Jahr angestoßen wurde, was ich insofern bemerkenswert finde, als dass das natürlich so ein naheliegendes Metadatum ist, was man eigentlich in so einem Video drin haben möchte. Letztes Jahr hat das glaube ich im Wesentlichen eine Person gemacht. Und dieses Jahr gab es ein etwas größeres Team, da ist also das eine oder andere experimentiert worden, unter anderem die Subtitles nicht nur live zu erfassen, sondern auch noch live mit auf den Beamer zu werfen, was mich so ein bisschen verwirrt hat, muss ich zugeben. Also das kam ja schon irgendwie in der Keynote und ich dachte am Anfang, das wäre jetzt Teil der Präsentation, fand das am Anfang lustig, später fand ich es dann eher, weiß ich nicht, irgendwann habe ich verstanden, was da passiert und dann war ich mir irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig sicher, ob ich jetzt unbedingt während ich in einem Saal sitze noch auf dem Beamer lesen will, dass jetzt gerade Applaus war. Aber bevor wir darauf rumreiten, muss man gleich mal vorne wegschreiben, es gab wohl auch sehr viel positives Feedback von Gehörlosen und auch Leuten, die jetzt weder mit Deutsch noch mit Englisch besonders viel anfangen können, denen das wohl auch eine Hilfe war. Ob das jetzt unbedingt live hätte sein müssen, ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Aber wie plant ihr denn mit diesen Daten umzugehen?
Also die Daten, die wir haben, landen glaube ich in so einer Plattform, die heißt Amara, die ist genau dafür gedacht, um Videos zu subtiteln. Das stammt glaube ich, wenn ich das jetzt nicht falsch wiedergebe, aus dieser Anime-Szene, wo die Leute da die Animes mit Englisch und Deutsch subtiteln. Na ja, jedenfalls, da landet das glaube ich alles nochmal und wird dann da nochmal Korrektur gelesen und ich glaube, die Barbara, die bei uns den Hut bei den Subtitles auf hat, schaltet die dann am Ende die Subtitles frei und dann landen die auf media.ccc.de. Genau, also das es Subtitles gibt, finden wir alle total großartig. Also es ist sowohl für Leute mit Hörproblemen, als auch für Leute, die zum Beispiel kein Englisch können, aber schön mitlesen können, einfach eine große Hilfe. Es ist halt eine Frage, wie macht man da Qualitätssicherung? Also wie sorge ich dafür, dass das, was im Subtitle steht, gerade live, auch wirklich das ist, was der Speaker gesagt hat? Und ja, wie du eben sagtest, es gab halt durchaus Leute, die es störend fanden, dass da nochmal Applaus stand oder so. Da muss man halt, wir werden da jetzt nochmal demnächst so ein Meeting zu haben, wo wir uns überlegen, wie das in Zukunft weitergeht. Also es soll das auf jeden Fall weitergehen. Es gab halt auch eine App, du konntest das halt dir auf dem Smartphone zum Beispiel auch angucken. Du konntest den...
Aber nur die Subtitles dann?
Ja, genau. Oder aber den Livestream mit Subtitles konntest du halt auch haben. Also die Leute, die draußen im Internet waren, konnten halt auch die Subtitles sofort haben. Ja, auf YouTube kommen die wohl auch. YouTube kann auch irgendwie Subtitles, aber...
Da haben sie dann auch so bis zu 100 Leute, hieß es glaube ich, im Walk Talk.
Die Leute, die den Subtitle-Stream konsumiert haben, waren auch durchaus eine nennenswert große Zahl, dass sich da für den Aufwand allein schon lohnt. Wie das jetzt im Saal weitergehen wird, da ist die Diskussion noch nicht abgeschlossen. Es gibt halt viele Leute, die uns zuerst angebrüllt haben, boah, das ist ja voll der Scheiß. Und dann haben sie verstanden, dass das aber für Leute mit Beeinträchtigung ist. Und dann sind viele auch wieder zurück, ach so, ja, na dann hab ich da Verständnis. Aber wir müssen einfach noch die Darreichungsform optimieren. Also ob man jetzt nächstes Jahr vielleicht einen zweiten Beamer neben dem Hauptbeamer hat, sodass einem das nicht immer ans Auge fällt. Oder ob wir allen irgendwie eine Google Glass auf den Kopf packen, müssen wir mal gucken, wo das hingeht.
Auf der Republika waren das glaube ich immer separate Screens nochmal. Die hatten ja eh diese kombinierten Videowende, wo sie dann mehrere Videoquellen zu einem Gesamtbeamer-Bild zusammengerechnet haben. Aber da war zumindest klar, hier wird jetzt irgendwie live transkribiert und das merkte man dann irgendwie auch. Weil es auch nicht so ist. Also ich glaube, was auch nochmal ein Problem ist, Subtitles sind ja quasi so getimte Einblendungen. Transkription ist ja eher so ein fortwährendes Schreiben. Und auf der Republika war es so, dass da dieser separate Streamer, das separate Beamer, war halt einfach so ein Running Text. Das heißt, da wurde die ganze Zeit der Text geschrieben, so wie er gesprochen wurde und scrollte so ein bisschen mit. Während das jetzt auf dem Kongress halt eben Subtitles waren und es eben auch deshalb verwirrend war, weil man eben teilweise nicht wusste, ist das jetzt die Präsentation? Ist das irgendwie Teil der Präsentation? Ich glaube, das muss man auf jeden Fall voneinander trennen. Also ich hätte da jetzt auch als Speaker Probleme damit, dass in meinen Wohl-Layout des Design eines Vortrags, der auch, sagen wir mal, so eine eigene Dynamik hat, im Idealfall, einfach irgendwelcher Text und zwar dann auch noch der, den ich gerade gesagt habe oder im Zweifelsfall noch irgendwas, was sonst auch passiert mit eingeblendet wird, was einem einfach auch die ganze Dramaturgie verhunst. Also so ein Transkriptionsscreen, der separat ist, den fände ich super.
Ich denke auch, dass es ein großer Vorteil wäre, wenn es halt eben nicht nur die Einblendung ist, weil oft haben ja Leute mit Einschränkungen nicht nur eine Einschränkung zum Beispiel. Sie sind vielleicht auch nicht so schnell im Lesen, weil sie auch noch optisch sehr nerv eingeschränkt sind. Das ist ja so etwas, wo ich noch so ein bisschen History nachlesen kann, eventuell noch viel hilfreicher als etwas, was nur ein paar Sekunden da ist. Also eine der Hauptintentionen von dem Subtitles-Team, das auf die Bühne vor allem dieses Jahr zu bringen, war halt auch einfach Aufmerksamkeit dafür zu schaffen, dass die Leute sich überhaupt mal bewusst werden, dass gibt es. Und dann haben sich auch direkt, glaube ich, relativ viele Leute gemerkt, ja, ich subtitle hier auch mit. Das war halt auch so eine so eine Etherpad-basierte Anwendung, glaube ich, wo dann auch mehrere Leute gleichzeitig reinschreiben konnten. Das hat dann auch wieder zu so Abstimmungsproblemen geführt. Wer schreibt denn jetzt eigentlich gerade? Und es sind halt auch teilweise dumme Sachen passiert. Da hat sich dann jemand quasi über den Subtitle mit dem Speaker unterhalten.
Und Tobias Talk, da gab es so eine kleine Situation, dann haben sie die auch irgendwann ausgeblendet.
Ja, also wir sind, damit das das gibt, sehr glücklich. Fies gelaufen ist noch nicht, aber ich denke, da wird sich jetzt einfach weiterentwickeln.
Was ja so meine persönliche stille Hoffnung war, dass sich quasi so ein Show-Notes-Team findet für die Talks und dass man danach auch so Metadaten zu den Talks kriegt im Sinne von Links und gut, das fällt bei den Subtitles wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen ab, aber vor allem auch so Kapitelmarken, fände ich auch mal ganz cool.
Also soweit ich weiß, haben die Show-Notes-Leute ja das ja auch für die ganzen Kongrestalks gemacht.
Echt?
Also ich will mich da jetzt nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, aber ich meine, das wäre passiert.
Bin ich da unterinformiert?
Da nicht so ganz in der Sache drin, aber zumindest hieß es im Vorhinein, dass da was passieren soll und das war halt auch so mein Wunsch, dass diese Subtitles und sowas wie Show Notes hinterher am besten zusammenläuft, dass man wirklich alle Metadaten hat. Die Links, die, was wurde erwähnt, welchen Wikipedia-Artikel muss ich klicken, damit ich weiß, was der gerade gesagt hat. Ja, also wenn gerade in dem Bereich Leute Interesse haben, meldet euch bei uns. Wir haben da auf jeden Fall noch viele Ideen und das muss nun mal jemand alles umsetzen, wie das immer so ist.
Googelt einfach nach der Peter und dann findet ihr bestimmt Kontakt.
Ja oder einfach c3wok.de, da ist so ein Kontakt-Dings vielleicht.
Dem Peter sein.
Wenn jetzt diese ganzen Subtitles dann überarbeitet worden sind auf amara.org, also quasi hast du eine Einschätzung, wie lange das dauern wird? Das ist ja letztes Jahr im Prinzip auch schon mal gemacht worden. Wie lange dauert das so? Einen Monat?
Das hängt total davon ab. Also das machen ja, das kann ja jeder machen. Man klickt sich da, glaube ich, einen Account und dann, ich glaube, die Barbara muss einen dann noch freischalten, damit das da auftaucht oder so. Ich habe es selber nicht gemacht. In jedem Fall, das hängt eigentlich davon ab, wie viele Leute das machen. Und ich weiß auch, dieses Jahr haben wir ja schon für sehr, sehr viele Talk-Subtitles, die nur noch gereviewed werden müssen. Das könnte natürlich dann auch dazu führen, dass das schneller geht. Und die landen dann ja, genau, auf Media halt.
Und was macht ihr dann damit? Dann macht ihr richtige Subtitle-Spuren in diese Videos rein. Das heißt, es gibt nochmal ein Re-Release von den Videos, oder sind die dann nur so separate SRT-Dateien?
Die liegen da als separate SRT-Datei. Also mir wurde gesagt, dass das das ist, was die Menschen haben wollen, die Subtitles konsumieren, weil sie das dann in den...
Mit den Menschen landen.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht in dieser Subtitle-Community drin, weil ich irgendwie glücklicherweise die Sprachen, die ich konsumiere, auch verstehe. Aber mir wurde gesagt, SRT ist irgendwie der Standard in der Subtitle-Szene und auf YouTube sind sie dann halt einfach im Video auswählbar.
Es ist richtig, dass das der Standard ist, aber es wäre halt trotzdem schön, wenn man sie halt auch noch als eigene Subtitle-Spur direkt ins Videofile mit reinbaut, weil da muss man nicht erstens immer noch eine zweite separate Datei durch die Gegend tragen und dann ist es quasi auch kompatibel, dann hast du es halt sozusagen auch mit dem iPhone. Das heißt, du streams irgendwie aufs Phone.
Also in den Webplayer wird es auf jeden Fall noch reinkommen, das kann glaube ich das HTML5 noch nicht richtig, da wird das aber noch reinkommen auf Dauer. Also dieses Re-Releasen von Files ist halt auch eine unschöne Sache, weil dahinter hängen dann ja zum Beispiel die Leute, die sich das schon mit ihrem RSS-Feed abgeholt haben, die kriegen das Re-Release sowieso wahrscheinlich nie mit. Dann hast du irgendwie diese Torrents, wie re-releasest du einen Torrent, das ist auch irgendwie nicht so richtig gut zu handeln. Dann stehen die verrücktesten Dinge so, das sind wohl die Videos, die wir re-releasen mussten dieses Jahr, wo Audio fehlt oder so. Dann hast du irgendwie so re-releasete Torrents, die die Clients trotzdem runterladen, aber dann bei 99 Prozent hängen bleiben und dann rufen die Leute was ist denn da los, das ist kaputt und also wenn man Re-Releasen vermeiden kann, dann will man das momentan noch vermeiden, glaube ich.
Ja, man müsste wahrscheinlich einfach das Konzept einer Versionsnummer mal gebären an der Stelle.
Da müssen es aber genau wie bei den mehreren Sprachen, müssen die Clients auch sowas wie Versionsnummern verstehen. Also ich höre jetzt Starbucks Talk Version 1.3, dann müsste der Client mir irgendwie sagen, es gibt davon überhaupt mehrere Versionen.
Ja gut, auf YouTube ist das nicht so ohne Weiteres machbar.
Ja, das ist noch schlimmer, die lassen einen Videos ja nicht löschen, du kannst irgendwie die deaktivieren. Du kannst das Video nicht mehr Public schalten, aber es bleibt halt da. Und dann hast du irgendwie in diesem schrecklichen Video-Manager eine Million Videos mit dem gleichen Thumbnail, die gleich heißen.
Super.
Man kann doch löschen, höre ich gerade. Na dann war das ein Missverständnis.
Apropos, habt ihr denn eigentlich schon die MCA-Takedown-Notices bekommen?
Soweit, ich weiß noch nicht, nee.
Das ist ja verwunderlich. Normalerweise jeder Kreti oder Pleti aus den USA diese Dinge überall hinfeuert, auch scheißegal in welchem Land oder sowas, wenn ihnen irgendwas daran nicht gefällt oder so. Deswegen finde ich das schon erstaunlich, dass bei dem Content und der Art und Weise und was ihr da auch macht und wenn da, wie gesagt, sogar irgendwelche Musik drin ist oder so, dass ihr nicht schon längst zugekackt werdet mit...
Na gut, ich meine, das kann natürlich jetzt auch auf uns zukommen. Bisher haben wir ja selber persönlich nicht auf YouTube released, sondern das haben irgendwelche Menschen gemacht. Wir haben auch mehrfach versucht mit denen in Kontakt zu treten, was nicht funktioniert hat und vielleicht geht das diesen DCMA-Menschen genauso, dass die diese Leute einfach nicht erreicht haben und ich glaube Media, CCC, die fliegt da einfach noch unterm Radar. Wir sind halt in der Szene, es ist das Portal bekannt, aber ich glaube so außerhalb der Szene wird da kein Crawler vorbeikommen, der irgendwie guckt, ob da Musik drin ist. Das könnte jetzt, wo wir jetzt selber auf YouTube auch releasen und auch in allen Videos, die Links zum Media drin haben, könnte das natürlich passieren. Also ich bin mal gespannt, es gibt zum Beispiel diesen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz-Talk, der fängt mit so einem Schnipsel aus so einem Fanta-Vierlied an. Mal schauen, wie cool die Fantas da sind. Werden wir jetzt sehen.
Das Problem ist, dass das ja gar nicht mal in der Hand der Künstler liegt, sondern es sind dann irgendwelche Verwerter, schlimmstenfalls die Gamer oder wie auch immer, die da ihr Schema erfahren.
So ist es halt, wenn man als Musiker seine Seele verkauft, ne? Dann kommt halt die andere.
Guck mich nicht an, der Musiker sitzt neben dir.
Ich hab meine Seele nicht verkauft.
Ich bin jetzt Mitglied in der C3S. Wie heißt das Ding? Ja, ich hab die dann gleich mal gefragt, wann kann ich denen zwar Songs anmelden? Aber das geht noch.
Ja, die brauchen noch mehr Genossen.
Ja, die müssen irgendwie noch an der Software stricken.
Tote Hunde und so, ja?
Ja, zum Beispiel tote Hunde.
Also mehr Genossen braucht das Ding, damit es dann losgeht.
Naja, sie brauchen halt irgendwie noch ein bisschen Geld, um weiterzukommen.
Naja, also insgesamt muss ich sagen, finde ich, macht das alles schon wirklich einen extrem coolen Eindruck. Dieses ganze Videosystem, wenn ich mir zurückdenke, wie das vor zehn Jahren noch war, we've come a long way.
Hast du mal da oben geklickt, dein Wunsch wurde übrigens erfüllt, wenn du auf das RSS-Symbol klickst. Gibt's jetzt rechts, nein, in der Webseite da oben? Da gibt's jetzt auch RSS-Feeds für die verschiedenen Formate. Du kannst jetzt nur H264 HD als RSS haben.
Dann kriegst du aber echt den Stallman, ne?
Dann kriegst du leider zum Glück nicht den Stallman.
Nicht versehentlich.
Tut nix? Na ja, eigentlich tut da was aus.
Na, da gibt es jetzt einen Podcast-Feed, den man dann kriegt, sozusagen.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall, sonst guck mal gerade in dem Page-Source, es gibt auf jeden Fall die Feeds jetzt für alles. Das hat Mario gerade eingebaut.
Ja, dann könnt ihr ja noch nach dem Podlauf-Subscribe-Button einbauen. Ja, und wie stellst du dir das jetzt so in der Zukunft vor? Also ich meine, was wäre jetzt eigentlich nochmal so wünschenswert? Und wo fehlt es an Geld, Material, Menschen, Ideen, Code?
Na ja, unser interner großer Wunsch ist, ich habe ja eben gesagt, wir machen sonst die Events in SD, vor allem wegen unserer Videomischer-Lösung. Und momentan fehlt es an einem Software-HD-Mischer. Wir sind eigentlich großer Fan von tue Dinge in Software, die du kontrollieren kannst, weil wenn so eine schwarze Kiste auf deinem Tisch nicht mehr tut, dann kannst du halt nichts machen, außer eine neue kaufen. Eine Software kann ich neu starten oder debuggen.
Ja, aber ihr könnt auch beides machen. Ihr könnt ja doch im Prinzip mehrere Quellen separat recorden, bevor es in den Mischer geht und nicht erst dahinter. Und der Mischer ist sozusagen nur der default Stream, der in dem Moment hergestellt wird, aber man recordet zumindest schon mal Multitrack. Und wenn man die eigentliche Mischaktivität parametrisch aufzeichnet, also quasi diese Information, welches Bild ist denn jetzt gerade zu sehen, einfach aufzeichnet, dann kann man das ja später nochmal neu remixen.
Das wäre auf der Wunschliste jetzt gleich gekommen. Also Multitrack-Aufnahme möchten wir auf jeden Fall. Also bis jetzt geht es dahin, dass wir sagen, wir können Slides und das Gemischte. Aber das ist halt vor allem...
Das macht ihr schon?
Die Slides-Streams gibt es glaube ich einzeln dieses Jahr. Also es gab auch separate Slides-Streams, die ganz unabhängig an der Pipeline vorbeigeführt wurden.
Mit dem gleichen Ton sozusagen. Ja, das wäre schonmal eine deutliche Verbesserung.
Das gab es auch auf der Player-Seite. Da kannst du irgendwie oben auf Slides klicken. Da gab es einen reinen Slides-Stream, vor allem für die Leute mit ganz low Band-Riss.
Das heißt, ihr habt im Prinzip in jedem Raum schonmal zwei Sachen aufgenommen?
Ja, die Slides haben wir noch mal einzeln. Die sind aber bis jetzt nicht so einzeln released. Mal gucken, ob wir das noch machen oder nicht. Naja, auf jeden Fall erster Wunsch ist Software-HD-Mischer momentan.
Warte mal, könnte man nicht diese Slides-Stream auch noch mal als zusätzliche Videospur in dieselbe... Also könnte man nicht ein Video machen, wo quasi Kamerabild und Slide als zwei Video-Dinger drin ist?
Ja, kann man die Slides nicht, weil man die hat dann ja als Bild, dass man die ohne Video, sondern als Bild irgendwie Show-Notes-mäßig so reinsetzt, weil man muss sie ja nicht als Video haben, ist ja völlig übertrieben.
Du brauchst ja nur einen Player, der zwischen diesen beiden, der so Picture-in-Picture machen kann, wo du im Player bestimmen kannst, wie du jetzt diese beiden Sachen sehen willst.
Also der einzige Videoplayer, den ich kenne, der zwei Videospuren kann, ist dann wieder VLC. Also kann man sicherlich reinmuchsen, kann aber wieder kaum ein Player.
Ja, aber wenn ihr diese Videos anbietet, dann kommen die Player. Dann hätte man endlich mal Material. Also ich kenne andere Projekte, zum Beispiel auch gerade hier aus dem Accessibility-Bereich, also für Videoaufzeichnungen, für Gehörlose, wo dann die zweite Videospur nicht die Slides sind, sondern die Übersetzung, die gehörlosen Sprachübersetzung. Sowas, also es gibt solche Player. Das lässt sich auch mit HTML5 problemlos machen. Aber es mangelt halt so ein bisschen an Content. Und wenn ihr sozusagen diese beiden Nur-Kamera- und Nur-Slide noch mal als separate Videos, also wenn ihr zumindest mal ein paar Demovideos machen könntet, ich glaube, das könnte, also wir würden uns da zumindest bei PodLav das gerne mal anschauen.
Ja, also wir hätten das auch alles unheimlich gerne. Das ist halt alles eine Frage der Hardware und der Pipeline. Aber das ist halt auch der Grund, warum wir den Software-Mischer wollen. Wenn wir einen Software-Mischer haben, dann fallen diese Features da einfach mit raus, weil wir die ganzen Videoströme sowieso in der Hand haben. Wir haben sowieso offene Prozesse, die diese Ströme damit Dinge tun. Und dann ist es viel, viel einfacher, da raus alles rauszuziehen, was wir wollen, als wenn wir jetzt haben, wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwie vor den Mischer hängen und davor nochmal alles wegholen und dann hinter dem Mischer nochmal das Gemischte. Das heißt, das multipliziert die Anzahl der SDI-Grabber, die du brauchst, das multipliziert die Anzahl der Rechner, die da Dinge tun. Und wenn wir einen Software-Mischer haben, können wir uns das einfach selber da rauspupeln.
Aber es gibt keinen.
Ja, es gibt zwei Projekte, die relativ dicht dran sind, was Funktionierendes zu haben. Und aus unserem Team jemand ist da auch sehr eifrig dabei, daran rumzupatchen. Und wir sind eigentlich ganz zuversichtlich, dass wir im Laufe des Jahres zumindest was für einen Testbetrieb haben. Ob das schon Camp oder schon 32C3 im Kompletteinsatz ist, weiß ich nicht, aber letztes Jahr war es jetzt zum Beispiel im Kongress so, da haben wir HD getestet, da haben wir Saal 1, einfach wirklich zwei komplette Chains nebeneinander gestellt. Es gab die HD-Chain, die war testing, und es gab die SD-Chain, da wussten wir, die geht. Und so werden wir es dann auch langsam machen. Wir werden dann halt erstmal parallel fahren. Und wenn das wirklich funktioniert, irgendwann dann vielleicht wieder ganz auf unsere Software-Lösung gehen. Das Schöne ist halt bei so einer Software-Lösung, du hast keine Spezial-Hardware. Wenn das Ding kaputt geht, dann fragst du mal ins Publikum, wir hatten hier noch ein Laptop mit dem Debian drauf. Und du lest drei Pakete, steckst es dran und dann geht es weiter. Das ist einfach auch ersetzbarer. Und die anderen Leute können es halt auch nachmachen. Wir versuchen es ja auch alles gut zu dokumentieren, dass andere Projekte oder andere Organisationen sagen können, ja cool, wir bauen uns sowas auch.
Also denkst du, ihr seid da schon auf der Siegerstraße mit diesem Softwaremixing oder könntet ihr da noch Unterstützung gebrauchen?
Da kann man auf jeden Fall noch Unterstützung gebrauchen.
Bereitschwertträger?
Ich meine, ihr hört ja ab und zu auch mal Leute zu, die ein bisschen gelangweilt sind, aber trotzdem wissen mit Videos drüben umzugehen.
Als Toolkit der Wahl hat sich da G-Streamer herausgestellt. Und wenn es da G-Streamer-Experten gibt, bitte, bitte bei uns aufschlagen. Wir können da auf jeden Fall Unterstützung gebrauchen. Und das Gleiche ist, ja, wie kommt man an die Slides? So Video Grabber ist halt auch ein großes Thema. Da gibt es gerade ein schönes Projekt, die das auf FPGA-Basis mal bauen wollen, weil alles, was es da kommerziell gibt, riecht irgendwie nach Lulu.
Ist das nicht sowieso alles von HDMI?
Ja, das ist alles irgendwie HDMI oder Display-Port oder derjenige mit seinem 10 Jahre alten Syncpad kommt mit VGA vorbei. Dann möchte jemand mit seinem Tablet, mit irgendeinem MLPD-Standard, also das, was du da kriegst, ist schon allein in den reinen Kabelformen. Also was über das Kabel geht, schon sehr verschieden. Dann gibt es halt so Dinge wie Auflösungen, so Dinge wie dein Rechner und die Gegenstelle, also im normalen Fall dein Bildschirm, unterhalten sich halt über EDID, also tauschen so EDID-Daten aus. Das ist irgendwie so ein I2C-Kram. Das muss man auch noch irgendwie durch deine Video-Grabber-Lösung durch und hinten wieder ankommen. Oder vielleicht hast du ein Y-Kabel davor, dann sieht irgendwie der Beamer das EDID, aber dein Grabber nicht oder andersrum. Also da kann man beliebig Spaß mit haben.
Ein Schlachtfeld.
Genau, also da ist auch noch ganz viel, was man gerne tun kann. Alles, was es kommerziell gibt, also so die Sachen so über 5K, das funktioniert so halb. Das sind so diese großen Scanline-Converter und alles da drunter. Also wir haben für die kleinen Events so IP-basierte Dinger, das ist ganz schön, aber da ist sehr viel Luft nach oben. Also dann immer noch.
Ja, liebe Hörer, wenn ihr sozusagen gelangweilt seid, aber mit Fähigkeiten ausgestattet seid, ihr könnt das ganze Thema Video-Streaming und Recording hier nochmal auf Vollermann bringen.
Es werden noch Breitschwertträger gesucht.
Breitschwert? Ich glaube, am Ende spielt das jetzt Hauptsache, es schneidet doch mit Mattenunterschied.
Also Double Longsword, da ist nichts gegen zu sagen.
Hauptsache, es choppt der Hydra ordentlich Köppe weg. Da nehmen wir auch Samurai und alles. Verstehe.
Für media.ccc.de nehmen wir auch sehr gerne Pull-Requests auf GitHub entgegen. Also wer da frontend webtechnisch was drauf hat, kann da auch gerne noch sowohl in JavaScript, als auch in, wie heißt das Ding, so ein Rubi-Zeug war das, glaube ich. Na ja, könnt ihr da mal pullen und Patchen machen. Wir freuen uns da auch über neue Features.
Der müsste ja dann vielleicht in die Show-Notes idealerweise sein.
Wir googeln für Sie live.
Der CCCC, also der CCC Colon, also vier Cs ist der Account. Da ist das irgendwie drin. Da ist das Media Backend und das Media Frontend. Da ist auch noch das XBMC-Plaket.
Und Ether 6.
Das ist aber geforkt. Das Media Backend ist sozusagen das Backend.
Das Frontend müsste da auch irgendwo rumliegen. Ich befürchte Webgen ist das.
Ruby.
Alles in Ruby. Das Frontend ist natürlich in einem anderen Account. Das ist nämlich in GitHub. Und da haben wir auch unseren ganzen Kram. Das Media hat halt so eine API, wie man sich das irgendwie von so einem Portal vorstellt. Da kannst du halt Streams gegenwerfen. Oder die kannst du halt irgendwie fragen, wie viele Viewer hat das Video und so was alles. Das ist das Backend und das Frontend.
Media-Binnenstrich-Frontend.
Kurze Zwischenfrage. Wir hatten auf unserer Stellung auch ein Eis mit drauf.
Das ist noch im Kühlschrank.
Ich wollte gerade nach Schoki schreien, aber auf jeden Fall war da noch was.
Mute mich mal gerade bitte kurz.
Kannst mal sehen, wie ihr hier in Luxus schreibt.
Geht nicht.
Das ist hier alles wie geht nicht. Was?
Denn Vogel ist tot.
Die Dashnick.
Ja, ist alles grauenhaft.
Ja.
So, jetzt wollte ich fast sagen nächste Haltestelle Camp. Stimmt ja gar nicht, ne? Also auf wie viele Events kommt das Wokzeug jetzt zum Einsatz pro Jahr?
Moment, ich hab da so eine Liste.
Ich hab da mal was vorbereitet.
Also 2014 waren wir auf 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, wenn man das Chaos-Radio mitzählt waren es 18 Events. Ja, nächstes Jahr kommen quasi noch auf jeden Fall zwei Events dazu, nämlich die Chaos Cologne, I2C heißt es glaube ich, ist ein neues Event vom Kölner Club.
Wann soll das sein eigentlich?
Das findet am 15.5. bis 17.5. statt.
Ist das wie der Pfingsten?
Und hat die schöne Internetadresse chaos.colone, also eine von den schönen Top-Level-Domains, die es jetzt gibt.
Chaos.colone, wenn man das eingibt, dann kommt erstmal nix hier. Ruf's erstmal.
Und natürlich das Camp, was wir dieses Jahr nicht hatten. Ja. Ja, 2015. 2014 hatten wir kein Camp, 2015 haben wir eins.
15. Mai. Ist das jetzt quasi die SIGINT mit anderen Mitteln?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine neue Location. Das ist, glaube ich, auch so eine Kunsthochschule oder Kunst- und Medienhochschule. Genau, also das war ja bei der SIGINT immer so eine Sache, dass die Location war ja so zweigeteilt. Man musste immer so zwischen zwei Gebäuden hin und her laufen.
Da wurde nur ein Tag oder was?
15.
Mai bis 17, ist klar.
Also da wurde uns versprochen, dass die neue Location total toll ist. Und ja, bin ich mal sehr gespannt drauf.
IC2. Nicht I2C. 1C2, Chaos Cologne, also der erste, oh Mann.
Die erste Chaos Cologne.
Okay, verstehe, Sie wollen jetzt sozusagen...
31C2 heißt es dann irgendwann, ja?
Okay, naja, also, oh Mann, ja, ich sage jetzt mal nichts.
Es wäre ja auch ein Wunder, wenn Berlin und Köln sich da nicht...
Ich finde ja, man sollte sich nicht zu sehr am Kongress orientieren, wenn man eine neue Veranstaltung macht. Aber schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt.
Ja, man sollte sich ja schon an was orientieren, was auch erfolgreich ist, ne?
Ja, aber man sollte es nicht immer so... Also, ich glaube, das war so...
So offensichtlich machen.
Das war so ein bisschen das... Ich will jetzt gar nicht schlecht reden, aber ich fand das so ein bisschen problematisch, dass die... Die Säcke in so ein bisschen... Wie das bei manchen anderen Veranstaltungen auch so ist, vielleicht ist das auch gar nicht so falsch, aber ich finde, man muss auch, wenn man was Neues macht, auch versuchen, was Neues zu machen und nicht immer nur so Kongress in klein.
Also, ich weiß nicht, auf dem Flurfunk wurde mir gesagt, sie richten sich glaube ich so ein bisschen mehr Richtung Demo-Szene aus, was ja auch...
Wer ist denn sie? Wer macht damit überhaupt...
Demo-Szene? Der CCC Köln.
Demo-Szene?
Also ich glaube, es geht mehr um Art und kreativer Umgang damit als um Security, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Vielleicht lehne ich mich da auch ein bisschen weit aus dem Fenster gerade.
Du, du lehnst dich ganz schön auch aus dem Fenster.
Der Erdgeschoss hier ist mir sicher.
Auf jeden Fall so richtiges Logo auf dem Twitter-Account noch nicht. Aber ich folge dem jetzt mal hier.
Du bist Nummer 17.
Ich bin Nummer 17, da bin ich nicht so richtig früh dabei, ne?
Du kannst ja mal auf Ihrem Abdotnet-Account gucken, vielleicht kannst du da noch eine niedrige Nummer abgreifen.
Gibt's den?
Okay, also das kommt, dann kommt das Camp. Das Camp wird sicherlich eine Herausforderung, auch so temperaturmäßig.
Ja, ich möchte dieses Jahr nicht wieder in einem Übersee-Container sein, in dem man nachts erfriert und tagsmilzt. Ich weiß nicht, so ein Büro-Container mit Klima wäre toll.
Falls das noch jemand nicht mitbekommen hat, Camp 13. bis 17. August.
Hatten wir schon abgefeiert in der letzten Sendung.
Hatten wir schon, aber man kann das nicht.
Wo du gerade teuer sagtest, gibt's denn eigentlich jetzt mal, fragen wir mal so die CCC-Insider, ist das jetzt so ein Kongress? Bleibt Arbeit über oder eher nicht? Oder zahlen da Leute drauf oder?
Du fragst mich jetzt zu Finanzen, da kann ich mich nicht zu äußern. Aber die Veranstaltung ist auf jeden Fall keine Katastrophe oder so.
Ich stehe unter Ende da, ich darf nichts sagen.
Ja, also das ist...
Aber das ist jetzt hier mal für Offenheit und Transparenz und bla und sült.
Es gibt da Offenheit und Transparenz, aber ich meine, bevor diese Veranstaltung noch nicht mal abgerechnet ist, ist es irgendwie sehr schwierig, jetzt irgendwelche Gerüchte in die Welt zu setzen, was irgendwie ist. Das weiß man doch nie.
Man kam ja gestern oder vorgestern der Lethal-Café, bis da mussten da noch Leute bezahlt werden.
Das ist jetzt gerade mal in Berlin ja ja. So eine Veranstaltung hat sehr viel Nachlauf und dauert einfach lange, bis das wirklich fertig ist.
Gibt es inzwischen eigentlich hauptamtliche Personal dafür?
Nicht wirklich so richtig.
Beim Abbau so ein bisschen, aber es ist nicht hauptamtlich.
Nee, hauptamtlich meine ich Leute, das ist eigentlich ein Event von der Größe. Also ich kenne Tanz-Events, die zwar auch groß sind, aber deutlich kleiner als der Kongress, die inzwischen echt drei, vier, fünf, sechs Leute hauptamtlich das ganze Jahr beschäftigen.
Ja, das ist...
Weil sonst einfach nicht stemmen kannst.
Ja, das kriegt der Club irgendwie trotzdem hin. Das ist eine schwierige Diskussion, mit sehr unterschiedlichen Meinungen, die auch regelmäßig neu angeführt wird. Ja, genau, das ist eine fortwährende Debatte. Grundsätzlich ist es aber so, dass der Club auch sehr gut damit gefahren ist, nicht so Positionen geschaffen zu haben, die langfristig Abhängigkeiten erzeugen, die man vielleicht nicht haben will. Das ist immer so ein bisschen so eine Grundangst im Club, dass man sich Strukturen eintritt, die dann irgendwann nur noch dafür arbeiten, sich selbst zu erhalten, wie das so mit Strukturen so ist.
Und da fahren wir eigentlich ganz gut mit, oder?
Du hast ja auch das Problem, wir haben ja im Event irgendwie weit über 1000 freiwillige Helfer und wenn du jetzt anfängst, ein Teil von denen irgendwie zu bezahlen, wo...
Moment, deine Helfer sind für eine Woche da, kriegen ja auch ein bisschen mal dafür. So ein Ding zu organisieren ist ein Jahresjob. Das ist eigentlich ein Fulltime-Jahresjob.
Es gibt auch Helfer, die sind auch ein paar Wochen da und es gibt auch ein paar, die sind ein paar Monate vorher und ein paar Monate nachher mit dabei. Also das sind fließende Übergänge. Ich weiß schon, was du meinst und das ist auch, sagen wir mal, immer wieder die Überlegung, weil es natürlich auf der anderen Seite für die Leute, die jetzt wirklich so eben im Mittelpunkt stehen und die vor allem auch mit ihren generellen planerischen Aufgaben natürlich auch dafür stehen, dass dieser Event überhaupt funktioniert. Es fängt ja schon an mit einer soliden Finanzplanung und den richtigen Entscheidungen, die man da treffen muss und das Ja und Nein zu Geld. Damit steht und fällt natürlich schon mal eine ganze Menge. Das sind verantwortungsvolle Tätigkeiten.
Wie geht denn das eigentlich? Gibt es da noch eine Veranstaltungs-GmbH drunter als Körperschaft oder geht das also aus dem Verein?
Es gibt eine Veranstaltungs-GmbH.
Die muss ja zum Beispiel ein Geschäftsführer haben.
Genau. Also 99 ist für das erste Camp diese Chaos Computer Club Veranstaltungs-GmbH gegründet worden. Die ist halt eine 100%ige Tochter des EV, damit man halt was hat, was im Zweifelsfall pleite gehen kann. Und dass man natürlich auch ganz andere kurzfristige Entscheidungen fällen kann, weil du kannst natürlich mit so einem Vereinskopf nicht irgendwie entscheiden mit, wir brauchen jetzt mal 1000 Meter Dampfbremsfolie. Das sind einfach so Entscheidungswege, die willst du einfach auf Vereinsebene niemals führen. Und dafür brauchst du diese GmbH einfach als flexibler Körper, aber letzten Endes ist das alles der Verein.
Diese Dampfbremsfolie, neu durch die Gegend getragen, willst du die mal wieder haben?
Dampfbremsfolie? Das ist so diese Folie, die im Hausbau in den Dachstuhl mit einsetzt. Das ist einfach schwer entflammbare, milchige, weiße Plastifolie. So relativ dick. Die haben wir bei Blinkenlights verwendet. Nicht im ersten Blinkenlights, aber im zweiten Blinkenlights in Paris und dann auch in Kanada nochmal.
Du musstest sie gerade im Lager schieben.
Nicht nur die Dampfbremsfolie, sondern das komplette Blinkenlights-Lager. Wir haben ja sozusagen unsere Installation 2008 von Kanada. Die 10 Paletten sind bis heute nicht ausgepackt worden. Weil wir ja leider noch kein Anschlussprojekt hatten. Bisher wollte das ja keiner. Vor ein paar Tagen gab es wieder ein komisches Hochhaus, wo sie auch Tetris drauf gemacht haben und sich total gefreut haben, wie super innovativ das ist. Aber wir haben das schon vor 13 Jahren gemacht und es noch nicht mal so gut hinbekommen haben wie wir. Aber anderes Thema. Aber das lagert jetzt so ein bisschen und hart so der Dinge.
Fermentiert, ne?
Trinkt Partinaat und so. Sieht bestimmt ganz nett aus danach. Aber wir haben ja, ich meine, wir haben da ein riesiges Reservoir an Technik, das kann man jetzt nicht wegschmalen. Wir haben 1.000 Baustrahler. Wir haben 1.000 wireless Dimmer, die irgendwie per Funk steuerbar sind, die irgendwie Graustufen erzeugen können mit diesen Baustrahlern. Wir haben, glaube ich, alles mal 1.000 Schraubklemmen, 1.000 Stative.
Die ersten Malereilstative sind beim Lageramtszug kaputtgegangen. Die musst du abziehen.
Wir hatten immer noch ein bisschen...
Aber es ist doch alles für die falsche Spannung, oder?
Kann man nicht 2D am Boden machen, für oben, dass sie so aus der ESS-Dit gucken können?
Wir machen Blinken-Lights nach oben.
Die Idee ist irgendwie auch schon seit 12 Jahren alt, die war vor 12 Jahren schon schlecht. Weil da ist niemand!
Du musst einen hochschicken!
Weißt du, wie viele Leute auf der ESS sind?
Ist egal, die twittern.
Drei?
Das können die nicht sehen.
Wenn du doch ordentlich Licht anmachst. Die können Osterfeuer sehen. Wenn ein großes Osterfeuer ist. Aber ernsthaft, da wirst du aber noch fucking Blinken-Lights hinkriegen, was die sehen können.
Wenn ich 1.150 Watt Baustrahl ankriege, wird definitiv nichts gemalt, was die ISS lesen kann.
Die müssen ja auch relativ weit auseinander sein. Ich hab ja nicht gesagt, dass die lesen müssen.
Das Problem ist, wir können die ja anmorsen. Ich hab ja gerade einen sehr guten Draht zur ISS, aber im August ist sie leider nicht mehr da.
Hier, Samantha alleine, 255.000 Follower.
Dann klicken die alle auf den Stream.
Hier Astro Alex, nochmal 200.000.
Der ist ja nicht da.
War das eigentlich vor der Dampffolie oder war da was? Ihr wart grad woanders.
Wir waren bei der...
Geld, Professionalisierung und Club und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das jetzt noch unbedingt weiter diskutieren müssen. So ist die Situation. So hat es bisher funktioniert. Jedes Jahr denkt man sich, so kann es doch nicht weitergehen, so groß wie alles geworden ist. Dann kommt der nächste Event und es geht trotzdem so weiter. Es ist noch größer geworden. Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wo das Ende ist. Beim ersten Camp hatten wir halt alle Horror, weil, oh Gott, Camp, da kommen 1500 Leute. Und das kann irgendwie 250.000 Mark kosten.
Das sind so Beträge.
Dann kaufst du heute Dampfsperr vor, Jens.
Das zahlt man heutzutage schon in T-Shirt-Einnahmen.
Ich kann nicht sagen, was dieser Kongress so an Gesamtsumfang hat, aber es ist ein Vielfaches davon. Und ja, so ist es halt. Die Maßstäbe ändern sich. Tja, jetzt haben wir das Vogue-Thema auch ganz gut durchgerockert, oder? Ja. Was ist überhaupt dein Gerät hier? Was fährst du da?
Du hast ja ein gutes Lenovo. Genau, ein X220 mit einem schnöden Ubuntu drauf.
Ich nehme immer gerne meine alten Macs, die so übrig bleiben oder recycelt werden oder von irgendwelchen Verwandten, die ich wiederkriege oder sowas, wo man nichts Aktuelles mehr draufspielen kann. Ich mache da gerne ein Ubuntu drauf. Die habe ich dann so bei meinen Netzwerkbastelein als Testgegenstellen oder im Nox als Testrechner im Endusernetz und sowas. Dafür sind die immer noch gut. Also die alten Macs meine ich.
Früher auch ein Mac, der verrichtet jetzt mit einem Ubuntu bei meiner Mutter seinen Dienst. Und die klickt halt auf Internet und Klickt halt auf E-Mail. Das geht auf jeder Plattform und funktioniert. Schönen Wartungsarm. Muss ich jetzt gehen?
Wir sind ja kein Mac-Podcast mehr. Hier wird ja episodenweise überhaupt gar nicht mehr das Wort mit A erwähnt.
Und wenn, dann schimpfen eigentlich nur.
Da können wir auch gleich nochmal ein bisschen schimpfen. Gibt viel zu schimpfen wieder.
Da warten die doch alle drauf, da draußen.
Ich finde, wir sollten mal hier so ein bisschen eher auf die administrativen Themen zu sprechen kommen, bevor uns irgendwie über Apple das Maul zerreißen. Oder?
Apple ist wirklich...
Wer will denn anfangen?
Was ist denn administrativ?
Na, der Huckel war doch tätig.
Das sind ja so Admin-Themen hier.
Alles Admin-Themen. Alles für die... So, habe ich das mal. Wir müssen mal mehr... Nee, ich habe überlegt...
Da gibt es eine kleine, lustige Nachricht. Dennis, hast du das hier noch aufgeschrieben?
Ja, der japanische Insolvenzer weiter, die haben sich ja mit diesem Bitcoin Exchange Kraken zusammengetan. Oder benutzen die zumindest als Bitcoin-Experten, dass die da mal ein bisschen drüber gucken, was dann bei Mt. Ja, der Typ, der das gemacht hat, war aber auch kein Japaner, dieser Mark Kapel ist. Und jedenfalls sind wir jetzt zu dem Ergebnis gekommen, dass es wahrscheinlich, also da steht was so, nur 90%, ich weiß nicht, was man da genau für Zahlen haben kann, aber dass es wohl... Da sind vielleicht ein paar Tausend Bitcoins nach extern verschwunden, also was relativ wenig ist, aber der Rest wäre wohl intern irgendwie verschwunden bei Leuten, die da wahrscheinlich gearbeitet haben, also dass es ein Insider-Job war. Das war's schon.
Ja, und der Chat hat's ja auch gerade schon gesagt, ist auch schon an mir vorbei gescrollt, Bitstamp hier, die RS.
Und Bitstamp hatte in den letzten Tagen auch irgendwie einen Unfall, wie viele Bitcoins waren das bei denen? 7000, 1500, ich weiß nicht, irgendwas für 5,5 Millionen, kann man sich ja umrechnen, wie viele Bitcoins waren.
Ich würde sagen, hier, we are compromised resulting in a loss of less than 19.000 Bitcoins.
Ja, 5,5 Millionen Dollar oder Euro, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, ob die demnächst nochmal wiederkommen, die sind wohl dabei. Also, weil die verdienen ja auch Geld, das heißt, wenn die 5,5 Millionen nicht allzu viel waren, dann stecken die das auch weg und machen halt einfach weiter, wie das halt in so einem Business so ist. Wahrscheinlich macht jede Bank das alle paar Jahre, nehmen sie ein paar Milliarden, so ach, ja, tut zwar weh, aber es muss jetzt auch keiner wissen, sonst gehen die Kunden ja weg. Das würde viel mehr weh tun, also wird das abgeschrieben und sie machen einfach weiter. Ansonsten, Bitcoin, gibt es noch irgendwelche News?
Kursfeld?
Ich habe auf dem Kongress, ich habe mir ein Apple-Display gekauft in Hamburg über Ebay und habe das da live abgeholt und ich hatte irgendwie keinen Bock, zum Automaten zu latschen. Und dann wusste ich, da ist jetzt gerade die Bitcoin-Couch und da bin ich dahin gelatscht, dann standen alle so und dann so, wer ist Käufer und wer will kaufen? Und ich so, ja Jungs, also ich will nicht zum Automaten und ich brauch jetzt mal 660 Euro und Hardware und alle so, äh, nee, viel zu viel, viel zu viel. Und dann der eine so einen Bitcoin, der andere so einen Bitcoin und dann hab ich da irgendwie Deals gemacht, hab ich noch einiges falsch überwiesen, weil ich mach ja immer mit Command-Line und so, ist mir ja schon mal passiert, da wieder. Dann saß Gott sei Dank noch neben mir, musste das dann gleich weiter schieben und so musste ich kein Geld abheben gehen. Ja, war ganz witzig. Und zwar wirklich schnell, also auch auf dem Kongress irgendwie. Ich hab bei mir geklickt und so eine halbe Sekunde, das war keine ganze Sekunde, da hat es bei dem Kling-Kling gemacht und war schon da. Also ist ja nicht confirmed, sondern die ist ja dieses Peer-Network, sondern er muss halt nur den Report sehen, dass ich es gemacht habe, das noch nicht bestätigt ist, gar nichts, aber er sieht, dass es sozusagen die Intention da ist. Und da ich ja daneben sitze und er das ja auch sieht, dass ich es gemacht habe, der wollte jetzt auch irgendwie da mehrere Runden warten, aber am Ende hat ihm der andere überzeugt, ach Quatsch, das ist gar nicht notwendig und dann war alles schön. Und als ich dann nochmal da war, dann hat er mich sogar erst an der Stimme erkannt natürlich, aber erst später, als ich nochmal hingegangen bin. Nee, aber war ganz witzig, habe ich eigentlich noch nicht gemacht bisher.
Du kannst ja in Zukunft auf das Video vom Sendezentrum verweisen, dann sehen sie dich auch.
Nee, wir wollen das ja eher weglassen. Es ist eigentlich ganz witzig, bis zu dieser Sendung, wenn ich mal Hochdeutsch spreche oder meine Stimmlage ein bisschen ändere, konnte ich mich echt mehrfach neben Leuten aufhalten, die sich über die Freak Show und über mich unterhalten haben, ohne dass sie mich erkannt haben. Zum Beispiel auf der Republika oder so. Das fand ich immer noch sehr schön.
Du bist ja noch nicht so lange dabei.
Ja, aber jetzt mit dem Video ist das jetzt auch passé.
Freak-Passee.
Freak-Cassee.
Ja, wie viele Leute haben denn das jetzt überhaupt schon gesehen? Auf YouTube.
Wie witzend, das wissen wir auf YouTube. Und hier unser Content-Mensch?
Der wisset nicht.
Der wisset nicht, das wollen wir auch eigentlich wissen.
Das sieht doch, das sieht doch was da aus. Nein, er sieht ein Minimum. Er sieht nicht alle da, aber er sieht ein Minimum.
Wir sehen halt nur die Klicks vom Browser-Player. Wer sich die Files einfach runterlädt, das zählen wir halt nicht. Freak Show, momentan 178 Views auf Media, die Leute, die es beim Browser geguckt haben, die es bei RSS angucken, den sehen wir halt nicht.
Und nochmal 4.300 auf YouTube.
Wenn wir schon bei Technik sind, will ich noch eine kleine Sache gleich heransetzen. Dieses Display, das ich gekauft habe, das ist so ein LED-Cinema-Display. Es hat gar keine Buttons, ganz komisch. Sieht so aus wie dein iMac hier, Timmer. Ist ja ein iMac, oder? Genau. Und keine Buttons. Und dann gucke ich irgendwie, man kann auch keine Brightness einstellen. Doch. Ja, warte. Ging nicht. Hab ich geguckt, gegoogelt, sagen die Leute, ja, nee, das geht automatisch. Also alle unterschiedliche Sachen. Bei mir ging gar nichts. Bis ich rausgefunden hab, dann, dass irgendwie, weil dieses Panel von dem Display wurde mal getauscht und die bei Apple haben vergessen, so eine EDID zurückzusetzen und solange die nicht in Sync ist mit irgendwie dem Display-Controller innen drin, wie auch immer, kommt dieses Brightness nicht. Und dann gibt es aber so ein Tool von Apple, damit kannst du das irgendwie wieder in Sync bringen und dann geht's. Also das heißt, wenn jemand so ein Apple Cinema Display hat und er kann keine Brightness einstellen, da gibt's so ein Tool für EDID zurücksetzen und dann geht's.
Also ich hab auch so ein Ding als Großglott, da fährst du halt einfach mit der Maus an der Display, nimmst die normalen Tasten da.
Ja, jetzt geht das ja auch alle bei mir. Vorher ging das nicht. Es war einfach keine Meldung, es wurde einfach nicht angeboten. Auch der Slider war gar nicht erst da. Das heißt, Apple ist dann so schlau, ja, der hat keine EDID, also dann zeigen wir auch keinen Slider an, fertig. Anstatt dass sie gleich sagen, hier, da ist was nicht okay, mach mal folgendes, aber nee, lassen wir ihn einfach weg. Naja, habe ich alles rausgefunden, geht jetzt alles super wunderbar.
Also dieses 21. Jahrhundert ist irgendwie insgesamt, also ich habe mir das noch echt anders vorgestellt. Das haben sie uns, also, ne? Der eben schon erzählt hat, diese ganzen, diese kleinen Insuffizienz, wie heißt das?
Du meinst, dass man in seinem Display Firmware auch updaten muss und so?
Ja, ich meine, ich meine, die machen, warum tauschen die das Display und...
Na, der Typ hat nämlich das gekauft, das war ja gebraucht, da war was kaputt und die haben vorne das Front-Panel erneuert und dann haben sie die Apple-Jungs selbst vergessen, das zurückzusetzen.
Ja, aber das ist doch nicht Future, Mann.
Nee, das ist Verteilung von Apple-Technikern vor Ort, wo auch immer das gemacht wurde. Star Trek ist eine Illusion. Das war in deiner Kindheit mal. Das ist Kinderfernsehen. Star Trek, da sterben keine Leute, zumindest nicht auf den...
Da draußen sterben die ganze Zeit noch.
Alle mit rotem Hemd.
Du wirst lachen, die gehen auch nicht mal auf Klo.
Ja, zum Beispiel dit.
Wird halt raus teleportiert, direkt aus der Blase, Alter. Kannst du am Rechner hocken bleiben, weißt du, und klickst dir aufs Knöpfchen und...
Ach man, die nehmen auch gerne Drogenhucke.
Vielleicht nicht in der Föderation, aber wisse, du kannst ja schon irgendwie auch deinen Shuttle nehmen und mal irgendwie auf Triptonium reisen.
Ey, Deep Space, gehst du ins Quarks, kriegst du alles.
Und kannst du sicher sein, dass irgendwie die Hacker, dass die da so ein Replikator auch nochmal ganz anders aufbauen können.
Und die Firengis verkaufen die doch zu Hause.
Apropos Shuttle und so, ich spiel ja Elite gerade. Und ich hab die letzten Tage so einer Piratenstation so viel Zeug verkauft, die finden mich jetzt voll toll. Ich bin bei den Green und die helfen mir jetzt immer. Du wolltest übrigens wissen, wie das mit den Sternen ist bei Elite, das sind die echten Sterne, die die da genommen haben. Da steht in der Doku, das sind alle Sterne, die du bei uns hier im Himmel siehst, gibt's in Elite. Die haben einfach mal die NASA-Datenbank da irgendwie reingepumpt und...
Korrekt. Na, ist ja auch ein bisschen sinnlos, sich da irgendwie was Neues einfallen zu lassen. Kennt ja iken.
Ja, früher haben die das gemacht, mit diesem Generieren irgendwie. Und heutzutage haben sie halt die Echten genommen und machen dann halt die Planeten in der Kreis, weil die haben sie ja wohl nicht alle, weil die wurden ja neuer nicht alle entdeckt. Die sind dann wahrscheinlich generiert, aber die Sterne sind wohl alle die Echten.
Toll. Dann nimmst du noch einige dazu.
Das können wir ja einfach da so einfügen und so, man kann die dann entdecken und dann gibt's auch Geld dafür, fürs Entdecken.
Es kreist ja gerade Gaia und macht den längsten Film aller Zeiten.
Die Gaia kreisen.
Ja, Gaia, das ist eine ESA-Mission.
Stehe.
Das ist so ein cooles Teil.
Der hat auch ein Teleskop.
Ja, das ist so ein fettes Teleskop, was nur unterwegs ist, um die Sterne zu zählen. Der kreist jetzt da hinten, wo schon Herschel und Plank waren, da in dem sogenannten Lagrange-Punkt.
Das heißt, das Ding ist noch mal fetter als das Hubble-Teil?
Nein, es ist etwas anderes. Hubble macht was anderes. Hubble macht schöne Bilder mit hoher Auflösung, damit man das sieht. Das Ding eiert jetzt einen längeren Zeitraum durchs All. Und versucht, alle Sterne, die ins Blickfeld geraten, der Milchstraße zu zählen. Das wird dadurch gemacht, dass das Ding rotiert und die ganze Zeit einen Rotationsfilm aufnimmt, während es mehrere Monate oder ein, zwei Jahre unterwegs ist. Sodass sie davon ausgehen, dass sie jeden Stern mindestens neunmal sehen. Manche sicherlich auch noch häufiger, aber jeden Stern, den sie überhaupt sehen, nehmen sie neunmal auf. Und sie werden ihn jedes Mal von einer anderen Position im All, weil das Ding fliegt ja quasi mit der Erde mit. Also es ändert quasi permanent seinen Fliegewinkel.
In jedem Weltraum bewegen wir uns ja fast gar nicht.
Mehr oder weniger statisch, ja. Aber für die astronomische Wahrnehmung ist das schon ein nennenswerter Unterschied, ob du auf der einen oder auf der anderen Seite der Sonne bist. Und dadurch kriegst du halt immer wieder eine andere Perspektive und dann kannst du halt aus der Bewegung und der Änderung und so weiter sehen, wie sich andere Sterne bewegen bzw. wo sie überhaupt sind, wie weit sie entfernt sind, dass es sie gibt etc.
Und ob einer dahinter liegt und so weiter.
Genau das. Im Prinzip entsteht da so der längste Film aller Zeiten, auch der langweiligste wahrscheinlich aller Zeiten. Und den werden sie dann wahrscheinlich auch sehr, sehr, sehr lange rückanalysieren am Ende der Mission.
Immer wieder übereinanderlegen und gucken, ob...
Ja, da müssen sie dann mit Obscura-Software jeden Stern irgendwie tracken und gucken. Und wo ist der jetzt, wie bewegt er sich etc. Also das ist der totale Voodoo. Aber das werden sie dann halt tun. Und danach gibt es die umfangreichste Sternenkarte. Dann hat man wahrscheinlich...
Dann muss Elite einmal neu importieren.
Dann müssen sie neu importieren und noch ein bisschen mehr RAM alluzieren.
Hast du dieses, ich weiß nicht, was, gestern oder heute, wo bei Heise noch mal dieses... Also da habe ich gelesen, dass von NASA dieses Bild, dieses Sternbild noch mal neu gemacht wurde. Dass man diese 400 MB-Version da runterlädt, was ich mal gemacht habe, und dann öffnest du und auf normale Quality rangehst, dass eigentlich alles weiß, weil ich meine, es gibt gar keinen schwarzen Fleck mehr im Weltraum, weil irgendwo ist immer ein Stern. Das heißt eigentlich müsste der Weltraum weiß sein, anstatt schwarz.
Ja, nur wenn es unendlich viele Sterne gäbe, dann wäre es so. Und das ist... Nein, gibt es nicht.
Sicher? Ja.
Sonst wäre ja alles weiß.
Naja, manche sind halt ein bisschen weiter weg.
Ist ja egal, kommt ja trotzdem irgendwie Licht an, und es würde ja nicht aufhören, Licht zu kommen. Und wenn es unendlich viele Sterne gibt, das ist ja sozusagen der Beweis, dass es nicht unendlich viele Sterne gibt, dass du halt nicht überall Licht siehst. Weil gäbe es unendlich viele Sterne, dann gäbe es überall Licht. Gibt es aber nicht, deswegen gibt es nicht unendlich viele Sterne.
Du meinst unendlich viele Sterne im beobachtbaren Universum, ne?
Ja, nee, überhaupt so.
Du kannst ja nur bis zum Hintergrund raus.
Du könntest welche hinter dem Ereignis hochbekommen haben.
Ja, aber dann, wenn, belast mich nicht. Ich hab die Aussage von Wissenschaftlern übernommen, die da sehr sicher waren und die wohl dann auch die ganze Ausdehnung des Universums und ich meine, wenn es unendlich viele gegeben hätte, dann hätt's ja schon immer unendlich viele gegeben und die wären ja dann für uns auch immer beobachtbar gewesen und was weiß ich, keine Ahnung, ist auch egal. Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht so. Und das Scheiß-Universum wird immer größer und es dehnt sich immer weiter aus und es dehnt sich immer schneller aus und irgendwann ist sowieso alles schwarz. So, das ist nämlich die Wahrheit. Ja, also würde unser Planet noch mehrere hunderte von Milliarden oder ja, was weiß ich, tausende Milliarden von Milliarden Jahren leben, wäre es hier irgendwann schwarz. Aber werden wir eh nicht, wir leben ja nur noch ein paar Milliarden Jahre. Dann ist Schluss hier mit Erde. Das ganze Projekt hier ist alles, egal wie viel Vogue-Infrastruktur wir aufgebaut haben, egal wie viele Podcast wir gesendet haben. Das ist alles für einen Arsch. Die Sonne wird sich aufblähen und jetzt auffressen und uns als kleine Staubteilchen auf Atomhallevel wieder ausspucken, damit sich dann nochmal 10-20 Milliarden später daraus wieder ein komplett anderer sinnfreier Planet herausbildet, der wahrscheinlich den ganzen Scheiß-Dreck wieder von vorne macht. Mit Nazis, Freak Show, alles nochmal.
Im Hintergrundrauschen gibt es dann Freak Show.
Hat die bei Star Trek auch alles schon, oder? Mit den Nazis und das hier nochmal und überhaupt und so weiter.
Hosten in irgendeiner Cloud außerhalb dieses Sonnensystems ist der nächste große. Da musst du erstmal Handstreamen.
Ja, da kommst du auch nicht hin, weil die haben bisher nur V4. Da reicht die Adressen nicht.
Auch unsere kleinen App-Erenzen, die sowieso noch hier irgendwie vorschieben, dann haben wir das weg. Ich hab schlimme Sachen gelesen.
Sagt gerade jemand, das Hintergrundrauschen bleibt in der Phonik hängen.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Angeblich gibt es da Mock-Abbilder, oder es sind ziemlich gute Bilder eigentlich, bei 9-5 Mac, oder wie heißen die? Wo ein MacBook eher 12 Zoll irgendwie abgebildet wird.
Was ja schon längere Zeit gerumort wird.
Aber einen 11 Zoll und einen 13 Zoll gibt es doch schon, oder wie?
Ja, aber es soll dann wohl nur noch ein Zwei übergeben.
Ja, macht ja, macht es nicht, keine Ahnung. Aber der große Aufreger ist, erstens, für uns jedenfalls ist der große Aufreger, aber die anderen interessiert das wahrscheinlich überhaupt gar nicht. Die Escape-Taste ist nicht mehr die obere linke Taste, sondern da ist jetzt der Ein- und Ausschalt-Button da.
Ja, tschüss, VI-User.
Genau.
Es sind nicht nur VI-User. Nicht nur VI-User.
Wieso?
Wo brauchst du sonst die Escape-Taste?
Ich drücke die nur im VI.
Eingabe-Failer?
Das stimmt nicht, aber ich benutze die richtig.
Wie gehst du aufs Eingabe-Failer wieder raus?
Ich benutze die ganzen Tage.
Ich tipp die alle ein.
Alle.
Nee, auf Tab.
Dann komme ich zum nächsten Eingabe-Failer.
Ja, aber der ist ein kompletter Dialog. Wenn du den canceln möchtest, dann klickst du immer auf den Cancel-Button.
Dann kannst du auch bis dahin tappen.
Manchmal schalte ich den Rechner aus. Und beim Coden? Tab-Completion?
Ja, mit Tab, wie gesagt.
Hands-to-Aim.
Da braucht man gar keine Escape mehr, oder?
Power-Taste links oben ist einfach mal Fail.
Das ist scheiße. Das wollen wir nicht. Riecht aus dem Mund und unterm Arm.
Aber dazu müsste man das Mock-Up erstmal glauben, oder?
Ich habe die furchtbare Befürchtung, ich traue Apple zu.
Aber dann, ok, das ist ja die eine Sache. Keine Escape-Taste. Viele werden sich denken, Escape-Taste, was ist das überhaupt? Aber das zweite Sache ist, es hat keinen MagSafe. Wie geht das? Wollen die auch hier so Laden machen über so eine Platte auf dem Tisch oder so?
Ja, aber USB Type-C ist doch ein Train-Rack. Das Teil hält doch nie was aus. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Apple diese Type-C-Dinger einbaut.
Und das ist dann auch wieder so ein richtiger Stecker drin. Das heißt, ich kann mir wieder meinen Rechner crashen, wenn da das Kleinkind übers Kabel stolpert und so.
Ja, das ist doch unglaubwürdig.
Ja, das ist unglaubwürdig.
Ich halte das auch für unglaubwürdig.
Aber wenn es passiert, dann...
Also Freak Show Meinung ist, Mumpitz. Wir brauchen da so einen Sound für. Tonne oder nicht Tonne.
Ich drücke den Mumpitz-Button.
Hopp or Top?
Wir können doch jetzt diesen alten nach dem wetten, das endlich expired ist, können wir doch diesen Sound von denen klauen oder so.
Wir können auch den Ted befragen.
Wir können den Ted befragen.
Ansonsten finde ich ja jetzt so 12 Zoll R finde ich einen interessanten Ansatz, insbesondere wenn es bedeutet, dass das Ding eigentlich genauso groß ist wie das 11 Zoll. Genau genommen, wenn man sich die Tastatur anschaut, stand hier nicht noch irgendwas davon, dass die Tastatur auch noch ein bisschen enger beisammen ist, dann ist das Ding ja nicht mal so groß wie das 11 Zoll R.
Da ist der Bildschirm, nutzt jetzt mehr, hat weniger Rand?
Da ist ja ein riesen Rand. Und wenn sie das schaffen...
Zeig mal was, wie das aussieht.
Dein Riesenrand.
Dein Rand, Timme, zeig mir.
Ja, das ist so schall. Ja, das ist wie früher.
Das ist 11 oder 13?
11er.
Ein 11er. Da hat ja mindestens zwei Zentimeter Rand.
Na ja, da ist eine Menge Luft.
Da geht noch was.
Da geht noch was, genau. Und das war so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, dass sie den Formfaktor im Wesentlichen so beibehalten, nur den Bildschirm ein bisschen größer machen, dass er sich etwas mehr ausdehnt, weil durch diese neuen Verklebungstechniken etc., die sie jetzt auch beim iMac etc. und beim iPhone gemacht haben, genau, haben sie ja gezeigt, dass sie in der Lage sind, einen dünneren Bildschirm zu machen und deswegen können sie auch in diesem Curved-Deckel durchaus es schaffen, da einen größeren Bildschirm reinzukriegen.
Aber was soll denn dieser Fetisch, dieses ganze Ding immer dünner zu machen, damit er überhaupt gar keine Stecker mehr für nichts mehr dran haben kann? Das finde ich völlig albern, ja, und sie beschweren noch nur das nächste Bandgate raus. Rauf damit.
Welches Gate?
Na Bandgate, da gibt es auch wieder Leute, die sagen, wenn ich mich jetzt auf diesen Rechner draufsetze, dann verbiegt der sich. Oder wenn ich da mit meinem Hambi drüber fahre, dann verbiegt der sich.
Ja, aber irgendein Gate wird sowieso kommen, also ob das jetzt Bandgate oder irgendwas anderes ist.
Ein Gate wird kommen.
Ich sag euch, das Einschaltergate.
Und zwar auf dieser Rapzeit. Jaja, ein Gate wird kommen. Ich weiß auch nicht, was ich davon halten soll.
Nächster Thema.
Ja, weg. Wir haben das nie gesehen.
Vielleicht ist das wirklich so eine Ladeplatte von unten.
Software-Quality.
Ja, genau. Wir haben ja schon oft über den App-Store und alles Mögliche geradelt. Wir haben uns über den José Mité schon beschwert in umfangreichem Ausmaß und die Welt da draußen ja auch. Auch wenn wir hier unter unseren Podcastern ja schon einige José Mité-User haben.
Hast du das eigentlich auch drauf? Mein Basel-Laptop habe ich es drauf, aber hier habe ich immer noch das andere.
Das Einzige, was nicht richtig funktioniert, ist halt hier irgendwie. Also WLAN geht jetzt seit dem ersten Update, aber dafür geht Bluetooth nicht mehr. Also bei dem Rechner in der Firma habe ich irgendwie den Boot-Dish so alle zwei, drei Tage neu, weil halt irgendwie die Bluetooth-Geräte weg sind.
Es wird Zeit für ein Snow-Usemity.
Ja, auf jeden Fall so langsam. Also ich hab ja auch letztens...
Snow-Apple, würde ich sagen.
Letztens hab ich halt auch wieder da gesessen und dachte mir, Mann, ey, früher hast du wirklich jedes OS, was nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen und von Apple kam, irgendwie installiert und geiler und besser und toller. Und meine innere Abwehrhaltung jetzt, dieses Rossemite, also ich meine, das hat auch mit diesem Audio auf jeden Fall zu tun. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt auch so wäre, wenn ich nicht so Audio-Setup hätte und das gerade toll finde. Und Skepsis hätte, dass es irgendwie... Mann, Alter! Skepsis hätte, dass das dann auch unter Rossemite reibungslos funktioniert. Vielleicht würde ich es dann auch sofort installieren, aber irgendwie so meine innere Resistenz gibt mir schon zu denken. Und jetzt hat hier der Marco Amandt, hat irgendwie auch mal so einen kleinen Rand-Blog-Post geschrieben.
Kleinen?
Naja, also, ich meine, der kann auch länger. Den konnte man schon in 5 Minuten gelesen haben, glaube ich.
Ja, es gab einige, die haben darauf reagiert, und irgendwie die ganze Echo-Chamber ist voll von, ach, die Software ist so schlecht.
Ja, da stand jetzt aber auch wirklich nichts drin, warum es schlecht ist, sondern nur das ist schlecht.
Naja, genau, aber ich dachte mir so, ja, okay, es resoniert, aber jetzt so ein bisschen halt umher. Und dann kam irgendwie gleich, hat irgendwie meiner Twitter-Heimlein einen Tag später oder so, kam dieser Blogpost von Panic, die halt hier Transmit und so weiter machen.
Aber das ist doch schon uralt, dass die nicht mehr, dass die ein Store nicht mögen, oder?
Ja, genau, die haben halt aber jetzt jetzt zum Jahresende ihren 2015 Panic Report irgendwie gepostet und mal fand ich mehrerlei Hinsicht interessant.
Also die haben jetzt mal gesagt, wie es ihnen ergangen ist, jetzt wo sie Coda, eines ihrer wichtigsten Produkte, aus dem App Store rausgenommen haben und direkt verkauft haben. Dass sie letztendlich unterm Strich genauso oder besser mitgefahren sind.
Ja, und dass sie jetzt halt irgendwie die ganzen Sachen machen können und Bugfixes und so immediately shippen können und irgendwie einfach der ganze Schmerz frei ist, also ist das wie so...
Ja, aber gut, das können sie als große Bude mit bestehender Kundschaft auch leisten.
Das sagen sie auch.
So ein kleiner Fuzzi ist, dann geht das eher schlecht.
Das sagen sie auch, aber das ändert nichts an der Tatsache, dass es einfach braun ist.
Für die Kunden besser ist so.
Und was ich aber auch ganz interessant fand an dem Post an sich, schreibt er irgendwie ganz unten ja nochmal so als Recap, dass die irgendwie 17 Jahre jetzt schon gibt und 17 Jahre Profit machen. Und das ist für so eine... also ich meine, Apple vor 17 Jahren, wissen nicht, was waren da gerade so...
Weißt du, was alles die Transmit gemacht haben? Gab es ja unter URs 9 und 8 schon, oder? Doch, schon, oder?
Aber es gab dieses Audion, dieses...
Die haben es hoffentlich gemacht, aber Transmit ist eine URs 10.
Aber fand ich auf jeden Fall auch immer ordentlich beachtlich, weil das ja eine ordentliche Nischenecke vor 17 Jahren noch war und die einfach auch so mit skaliert mitgewachsen sind und irgendwie immer am Start waren. Und insgesamt fand ich den Blogpost einfach mal erwähnenswert und lesbar. Und ja, irgendwie so generell dieser Vibe, der sich auch bei uns in der Freak Show einschleicht, das wäre jetzt so generell immer so...
Nase rümpfen.
Ja, man hat so ein bisschen Angst.
Die Erwartungshaltung ist jetzt echt so dieses... Es kann nur schlimmer werden.
Du wirst nicht schlechter und du wirst älter geworden.
Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Keine Risikobereitschaft mehr.
Also allein dieses iCloud Drive-Fiasco, was sie jetzt heraufbeschworen haben...
Du, ich kenne sehr viele Leute, die...
Ja, aber benutzt ihr das?
Nee.
Also ist das nicht die Quelle eurer Probleme?
Nein, das Schlimmste an iCloud Drive ist halt, du stellst entweder um oder du lässt es bleiben. Und es gibt halt diverse Leute, die es nicht raffen und dann irgendwie ein Device auf iCloud Drive haben und eins nicht und dann sind die Daten nicht da, wo sie sie erwarten und so weiter. Das ist wieder ein totales Chaos und du kannst nicht zurückgehen und es ist...
Ja, aber das sind ja nicht eure Probleme, das sind ja die Probleme von anderen Leuten. Erzählst du mal über eure Probleme.
Das sind doch meine Probleme, weil ich muss ja die ganze Zeit gegen die Windmühlen ankämpfen.
Ich habe andauernd die ability issues auf all meinen Apple-Devices, die machen lauter komischen Quatsch. Es ist jetzt nichts Fatales, aber trotzdem so Sachen, wo ich mir jedes Mal, wenn ich das sehe, denke, ey, wenn Steve jetzt noch leben würde, hättest du das A nicht gegeben? Und B, wenn er das sehen würde, der würde sofort über 20 Leute feuern, die vorher verprügeln. Und zurecht.
Oder auf dem Schreibtisch kacken oder sowas.
Und zurecht. Also das ist wirklich echt...
Ja, vielleicht hat es damit zu tun, dass der Tim Cook einfach so ein bisschen zu soft ist. Nicht mehr mit harter Hand regiert wird. Ja, oder sie haben sich halt zu sehr auf Notebooks flacher machen, was ja so der Tenor von dem Marco war. Die kümmern sich jetzt halt um Hardware und irgendwie das alles geiler und irgendwie den ganzen Production-Chain und alles irgendwie zu streamline und dass eben jetzt hier die OS-Releases so im Jahresrhythmus aus der Tür gepusht werden so dazu, dass dann halt irgendwie...
Aber haben wir nicht alle gesagt, doch endlich geil jedes Jahr Software-Updates und nicht mehr irgendwie zwei Jahre warten?
Nee, ich hätte gerne jetzt wieder sowas wie damals Snow Leopard, sozusagen so ein No-Features-Ding. Ich hätte jetzt gerne ein No-Features-Usimity, ein Snow-Usimity hätte ich gerne.
Wenn ich mich recht erinnere, waren es dann aber doch irgendwie 200 No-Features.
Ja, unten drunter. Die sollen es ja in Ordnung bringen. Und vor allem ihre Bugs fixen.
Snow reicht schon nicht mehr, ich brauche Ice-Usimity.
Aber die Hardware, ich meine, sie löten jetzt überall irgendwie das RAM fest. Also ich meine, der Mac Mini ist Müll. Diese komische Mülltonne ist auch Müll. Also, weil das ist kein Mac Pro mehr.
Und mit der Escape-Tasse schaltet man jetzt den Rechner aus.
Aus dem Insert-Modus raus.
Ist ja vielleicht eh besser so insgesamt.
Und auf der anderen Seite finden wir aber die 12-Stunden-Akkulaufzeit voll toll.
Ich frage mich auch immer wieder so, ich hätte ja gerne mal noch ein tolleres R. Ich bin sehr zufrieden eigentlich mit meinem aktuellen Gerät. Finde es super, das 2013er hat irgendwie echt viele Features. Dann denke ich mir so, ah, baut doch mal was, was ich lieber hätte.
Nee, dann denke ich mir immer so...
Die bauen bestimmt wieder irgendwas ein oder aus, was mich irgendwie davon zurückhält. Aber ich habe immer keine Ahnung, welche Gemeinheit sie sich wirklich einfallen lassen. Und dann kommen sie mit so Sachen wie...
Make safe! Da wäre keiner drauf gekommen. Damit haben die nicht gerechnet.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du den gar nicht mehr laden, sondern kannst den nur einmal laden. Du kriegst den einfach, so wie du das RAM festgelötet hast, kriegst du auch einfach eine Energieladung.
Und man kann auch keine Files verlöschen. Das Volles ist vorbei.
Ja, das hält dann auch lange. Und dann musst du immer alles auf iCloud dreifen und dann kaufst du den nächsten Rechner.
Jahresrechner, so wie Jahreswagen.
Ja, da ist ja alles drauf.
Wer will denn da noch laden?
Bis dahin hast du doch schon wieder eine neue Maschine.
Jetzt weißt du auch, warum das MacBook da keinen Lade-Stecker hatte auf dem Bild.
Aber das Schlimme ist ja, es gibt ja auch keine Alternative. Jetzt sagt Peter, wie war das Moment?
Nee, es ist ja schlimm. Lenovo ist ja auch auf diesem Apple-Trend. Die bauen ja alle guten Features aus, um die Dinger flacher zu machen.
Ja, aber die sind ja immer ein Jahr hinterher. Das heißt, man hat ein Jahr Zeit, um schnell noch bei den PC-Jungs das dicke Laptop abzugreifen, bis sie es dann auch machen.
Wie ist denn das? Kannst du mal ein bisschen Einblick geben in die aktuelle Syncpad-Landschaft? Gibt es überhaupt noch Geräte, die man haben will?
Na ja, also vom Feature-Set gibt es ja das Lenovo MacBook, also dieses X1 Carbon. Das ist ja mehr oder weniger also hat jetzt auch das riesen Trackpad und so weiter alles bekommen. Ist halt ein nettes Gerät, aber sie haben halt so das, was einen so ein Syncpad ausgemacht hat, so Rock-Solid-Dock-Connector, da haben sie auch angefangen RAM einzulöten, also all diesen Quatsch haben die halt leider auch übernommen. Es gibt aus der T-Serie, kann ich mir irgendwie die Nummer nicht merken, ein ganz schönes, aber sonst ist es echt dünn gesät. Ich bin großer Fan der X-Serie, aber mit dem X240 haben sie halt auch aufgehört. Da kannst du momentan mit maximal 8GB RAM bestücken. Also das Ding ist genauso groß wie mein Notebook und sie haben nur einen RAM-Slot verlötet. Das Ding ist im Wesentlichen leer, das macht gar keinen Sinn.
Und jetzt die Preisfrage. Ich sehe bei dir, sehe ich noch, haben die aktuellen Lenovo-Geräte immer noch einen VGA-Connector dran?
Die X-Serie hat es, glaube ich, noch. Die dünneren natürlich nicht mehr.
Aber wie willst du auf deiner Konferenz sonst nicht an den Beamer ranstecken? Nein, haben die da nicht. Könnte VGA sein.
Nee, das ist mittlerweile, weil alle mit ihren Laptops...
Aber die machen auch Powerpoint.
Also ich hoffe wirklich drauf, dass das X-250, was so zyklusmäßig jetzt bald mal announced werden müsste, dass sie da irgendwie wieder den Weg in die richtige Richtung finden, weil einfach im ganzen professionellen Bereich die Leute aufschreien, was soll denn das? Ich will mit dem arbeiten, es muss nicht noch dünner werden, es muss einfach nur funktionieren. Und vor allem haben sie halt den Docking-Station wegoptimiert, die ich immer so das Killer-Feature fand. So draufstecken, alles connected, alles toll. Ja, du hast halt bei denen halt immer hier unten so ein leider-propertären Dock-Connector. Und der passt halt immer auf die Notebooks so grob, der X und T-Serie von so einem Jahrgang oder zwei Jahrgängen meistens, dann brauchst du wieder ein neues Dock, aber da drauf liegt halt alles. Gigabit Ethernet, USB 3, HDMI...
Wer hat denn jetzt hier seinen Telefon?
Ich wollte aber eigentlich was anderes testen.
Du sollst nicht testen, hier sollst du einfach...
Podcasten!
Das brennt doch auch vorhin gar nicht wieder weg.
Ja, ja. Du mich auch. Erzähl weiter.
Ja, also dieser Dock-Connector war halt eine feine Sache, aber das haben sie bei den neuen dann zugunsten von flacher Wegrationalität.
Was geht denn rüber über den Dock-Connector?
Na ja, alles, was du irgendwie anschließen willst.
Was denn?
USB 3, Gigabit Ethernet, ich habe zweimal Display-Port mit voller Auflösung da drüber, also ich kann zwei dicke Panels da dran hängen, Audio in Analog und Digital.
Also wesentlich das, was man so über Thunderbolt macht auf dem Mac.
Genau, also das, was du am Mac dann an so einem Thunderbolt-Dock irgendwie machst und Strom halt auch. Also du steckst ihn drauf auf dein Dock und es ist wirklich alles angeschlossen, was man sonst irgendwie dran stöpseln könnte und mehr.
Gibt es denn Thunderbolt eigentlich auch für Lenovo?
Ich glaube, dass die, die neuen Syncpads das auch haben. Also meins hat es noch nicht, aber die, die die Mini Display Port haben, da ist es teilweise glaube ich drin. Zumindest stand das mal auf der Webseite announced, aber Sprich, das Mini Display Port ist mittlerweile auch Thunderbolt sozusagen. 1x250 wurde scheinbar angekündigt, lag der Chat.
Nächstes Mal, unser Chat ist hier voll auf Zack.
Ja, wann wären wir ohne unseren Chat? Unter anderem.
Naja, und was halt auch großartig ist, du hast halt noch, selbst bei den kleinen Geräten, meistens zwei Mini, ein bis zwei Mini PCI Express Ports, wo du halt einfach, ich hab in meinem zum Beispiel eine zweite SSD nachgerüstet, als ich das UMTS Modem irgendwann nicht gebraucht habe und so, das ist halt schon sehr nett.
Ja, jetzt gibt es ja einen X1 Carbon für dich.
Ja, das Carbon ist ja das momentane Flaggschiff, aber das 250 wäre interessant.
Das 250 sieht aus, als wäre das aber auch wirklich immer noch ein riesen Klopper.
Wen kann man da LTE reinstecken?
Steht aber 12,5 Zoll, also so riesen Klopper.
Aber es sieht so dick aus, guck mal, jetzt geht es bei mir auch schon los.
Also, Schlankheitswahn hier.
Und dann wundert man sich, warum eine Dremm festgelötet ist.
Das ist aber nicht viel dicker als der VGA-Stecker. Die wiegen auch gar nicht so viel.
VGA-Stecker, das ist so bekloppt, ey. Von allen Sachen könnten sie das wirklich am ehesten weglassen. Ich habe Jahrzehnte gefühlt, aber es ist wahrscheinlich nur eins.
Länger, als wir unsere Sendung machen.
Wie oft hast du schon irgendwo deinen Adapterschnupsi gesucht, wenn du irgendwo warst?
Noch nie.
Den kriegt man in der Regel in die Hand gedrückt.
Also im Titanium-Powerbook, da war noch VGA, oder? Doch, hinten.
Das war auch zehn Jahre her oder zwölf.
Also das könnte ich mir noch vorstellen, aber ich glaube danach...
Das war 2003 war das.
In den Alus haben sie es glaube ich nicht mehr drin gehabt. Mac Tracker, Visus, Common.
Ich bin schon dabei. Ich tracke alles was bei Dry nicht oft.
Ja, da gibt es ein Bild vom 250, das hat VGA. Das Einzige, was mich so ein bisschen an HDMI nervt, ist, dass er auch gleich das Audio abzieht.
Man muss dann immer wieder zurückschalten.
VGA, das Powerbook.
Wenn ich mein Notebook zu Hause aufs Dock stecke, dann sind da zwei Bildschirme, die Audio können und eine Soundkarte, die Audio können. Auf einmal macht es flump und...
Habe ich das gemacht?
Klick mal auf der Dicke.
Ich wollte ein Bild von dem Teil haben.
Er klickt noch trotzdem, ob du das denkst, ob du das machst.
Aber hier, du musst bei History mal klicken, da sind Bilder und das ist das Titanium und das hat VGA. Also Titanium hatte noch VGA und das Powerbook gab es. Es gab ja auch ein Powerbook G4 in Alu. Mal gucken.
G15 hatte auf jeden Fall schon DVI.
Also die ganzen Intels hatten schon keinen VGA mehr. Ja, das war 2006.
Neun Jahre, zehn Jahre, tatsächlich.
VGA, das ist auch wirklich, also mittlerweile brauchst du dafür ja über einen Adapter bei.
Damals bin ich mal von so einem Schlipsy-Typ komisch angeguckt worden, als ich zu nur meinte, VGA, Ancient Technology. Aber du hast es halt auch in den Konferenzzentren oft, dass wenn du da vielleicht HDMI machen kannst, steckt da meistens so ein HDMI zu VGA, weil...
Na, wenn die ganzen PC's auch immer mit VGA kommen, dann werden die davon ja auch nie abrücken.
Ja, aber das ist halt auch verbaut, das funktioniert, ne? Die Strecken können länger sein, die Kabel können länger sein.
Ja, aber das ist analogiker Scheiße.
Du kannst Full HD über VGA machen, das ist nicht hübsch, aber es geht.
Du meinst, du hast nicht so viele Pixel, aber ansonsten ist es Full HD. Es sieht so aus wie Full HD.
Es franzt so ein bisschen aus an den Kanten und so.
Super Vortrag.
VGA-Versteher.
Die Sendungstitelliste, bitte. VGA-Versteher.
So, jetzt mal nicht frech werden hier zu den Gästen.
Der Peter, der weiß doch, wie der Hase läuft. Der ist doch auch schon lange im CCC-Stahlbad abgestrahlt worden irgendwie.
Wir haben diese ganze Adapter-Nummer ja auch oft durchs Wok hinter uns, wenn du da so eine Kiste liegen hast, um da alle anzuschließen. Das ist übrigens das hartnäckigste Problem. Das sind Speaker, die mit einem Mac kommen, mit einem aktuellen USX, weil dann siehst du ja die Screen Resolution-Settings immer auf dem Screen, den du gerade einstellen willst. Wenn dein Mac dann aber meint, naja, ich mach da mal Full HD und der Beamer in diesem Konferenzraum das aber nicht kann, siehst du halt nichts und dann behaupten die immer hartnäckig, nein, nein. Das ist alles richtig eingestellt, weil sie diesen Dialog ja gar nicht sehen können. Es gibt irgendeine Zaubertasten-Kombination, dann kommt der auch auf den ersten Screen.
Es gibt auch ein Button, Gather all Windows.
Er hat Button gesagt.
Lasst mal lieber noch ein bisschen raten.
Geil fand ich ja diese Story, wo irgendwie so ein Macbook Pro, habt ihr das gesehen, wo so ein Macbook Pro irgendwie so ein bisschen aus dem Binsen ging. Was hat der Typ gemacht, um das Ding wieder zum Laufen zu bringen? Er hat es in den Ofen geschoben.
Ja, aber fünfmal irgendwie.
Ja, er ist immer wieder abgeraucht und dann hat er dann irgendwie noch ein paar Löcher reingedrillt. Und als er das dann gemacht hat, dann hat sich das dann irgendwie die Wärme dann auch entsprechend verteilt. Aber das hat auf jeden Fall die Lebensdauer seines Geräts enorm verlängert.
Hast du die Diskussion darunter gelesen?
Nee, aber du warst...
Die war geil!
Also...
Ja, naja, waren halt einige der Meinung, dass das so ziemlich die blödeste Idee ist, die man haben kann, da Löcher reinzubohren.
Ja.
Irgendwie... Also einige haben dann auf die Apple-Entwickler gerantet, dass die das nicht im Griff hätten mit dem Airflow und so weiter. Und dann andere wieder, nein, die wissen, was die tun und so. Also der Artikel selber ist nicht so spannend, aber schaut euch die Diskussion an.
Wenn ihr lange Weile habt.
Nur ist es schon kurzweilig. Also...
Ja, aber ich finde das schön, wenn man sozusagen so ein Gerät, wenn es eh nur noch darum geht, dass es überhaupt läuft.
Mit dem Ofen hat man doch schon öfter mal hier auch in einer Sendung, als Fib hab ich schon mal erzählt.
Also ich finde es erstaunlich, dass so ein Gerät das überhaupt überlebt. Aber er hat es wahrscheinlich...
Ja, er hat ja alles ausgebaut, was nicht...
Ja gut, aber ich meine auch, dass die Platine das so überlebt.
Naja, die wird ja sowieso ge-reflowed, also...
Die wird so hergestellt.
Was meinst du, wie SMD-Löten funktioniert heutzutage?
Da sitzen nicht zwei mit, da werden alle Bauteile fest geklebt und dann kommt es in den Ofen und wird gebacken.
Ok, also ich meine so eine Reflow-Kurve, die ist relativ kompliziert, wenn man die richtig einhalten will, dann muss man die richtige Steuerung dafür haben und dann sind es auch nur Minuten bei 300 Grad oder so.
Deswegen hat er auch geschrieben, er hat genau ausgetimt, sieben Minuten und beim dritten Mal Backen hat er sich dann getraut, ihn mal sieben, eine halbe Minute zu backen.
Aber trotzdem ist es eigentlich nichts, was man mit so einem Haushaltsbackofen machen möchte.
Komm, wenn das Ding sonst eh in einer Tonne landet, ist sozusagen dein Last Resort. Das heißt, du schmeißt es weg oder tust es vorher noch mal sieben Minuten in den Ofen?
Ja, und zwei Tage später packst du deine Plätzchen da drin? Hallo? Es gibt so schöne Bausätze, wo du einen Backofen anschließt und sie machen PWM auf der Stromleitung, um da Temperaturkurven hinzukriegen.
Ich weiß. Aber hier, die Apple-Rechner, die sind ja alle Azen-free und so weiter. Also da ist ja nichts Giftiges mehr drin.
Der nicht, der ist so alt.
Was denn?
Der bleibt noch vor sich hin.
So, kommen wir zur Administrationsecke.
Du hast Urlaub und Langeweile.
Und machst so ein bisschen Commandline-Sport.
Ja, ich mach wieder ein bisschen die Administrationsmuskeln flexen. Auch weil, aus Anlass eigentlich, wollte ich das schon lange machen, aber ich musste jetzt, weil ich so ein bisschen Infrastruktur abgeben musste, weil ich hab in der Uni da, wo ich in dieser Fakultät da so zugange war, da war ich ja auch so administrativ tätig und ein Trick, der mir immer so geholfen hat, um die Infrastruktur, die ich nicht meine, ist aktuell zu halten, ist sie mit zu benutzen. Und dann, als ich dazu mal kam, da ein Mails habe aufzusetzen, dachte ich, na gut, wenn ich das mache, dann irgendwie schiebe ich mal meine Mail da auch drüber, weil erstens kümmere ich mich dann, was? Genau, schiebe ich meine Mail auch drüber, weil dann kümmere ich mich halt auch drum und bin auch selber daran interessiert, dass es läuft genauso mit dem DNS-Server, den habe ich sozusagen auch einfach mit benutzt, weil ja, dann kümmert man sich halt. Und das musste ich jetzt mal so langsam abgeben an meinen Nachfolger. Und deswegen hatte ich jetzt, wo ich gerade noch Urlaub hatte, so den akuten Bedarf, einen neuen Mail-Server aufzusetzen. Und habe das jetzt mal so an einem Tag tatsächlich gewuppt bekommen und ich habe um 12...
Du bist aber noch nicht fertig.
Ich bin noch nicht hundertprozentig fertig. Aber Mail geht rein und Mail geht raus und Spam wird auch wegsortiert und...
Wobei man jetzt dazu sagen muss, dass ich bin ja auch ein bisschen höhlhörig geworden, weil ich war jetzt auch mal wieder dran und ich bin jetzt noch dran, auch mal meine Infrastruktur, mal wieder aktuellen Updates und sowas zu unterwerfen. Man kann sowas sich auch fertig klicken. Du hast auch ein bisschen Spaß am Gerät und möchtest es natürlich auch gerne auch mal richtig machen, denn nicht einfach eine V-M klicken. Oder ein OSX-Server oder sowas installieren, wo das dann alles einfach drauf ist, aber halt vorkonfiguriert von irgendwelchen Spacken. Sondern du und ich, wir machen das ja auch, weil wir so ein bisschen Spaß daran haben, das dann auch gerne richtig machen wollen. Oder dann so sagen so, ja, wir setzen jetzt nicht einfach nur einen Mailserver auf, sondern auch einen, der bitte auch alles korrekt macht, was so heute so angesagt ist.
Und vor allen Dingen, ja, weiß nicht, es gibt ja sowieso immer die Leute, die fragen ja, wieso eigenen Mailserver, warum nenne ich G-Mail und so rum. Ja, so eine Diskussion fürchte ich dann halt auch gar nicht mehr, weil ich weiß schon, in eurer Bubble, oder in der Bubble von den Leuten, da sind halt meine Argumente auch einfach komplett irrelevant.
Sagt dir mal, genau die Leute fallen dir zwei Gigabyte später wieder raus aus der Bubble und stehen dann vor dir und sagen, wie kriege ich den jetzt mein 1&1-Mail-Account, der sagt mir immer erst voll, wie kriege ich das denn hin? Und dann sagst du, gar nicht. Weil der hat halt ein maximales Heißlimit von 2G, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht, ob das immer noch so ist, aber vor ein, zwei Jahren war das so. Und es gibt dann auch keine stinkende Möglichkeit, das da irgendwie zu erhöhen. Nicht mal gegen Geld oder sonst irgendwas. Die einzigen, die da immer noch spacemäßig relativ cool sind, oder die einzigen von den großen, ist halt Google. Aber die ganzen Leute, die alle bei web.de oder sonst irgendwas waren oder bei 1&1 oder so, fallen früher da später damit doch auf die Nase.
Und E-Mail für mich persönlich, muss ich ja sagen, ich hab's ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt, ist ja immer noch eines meiner absoluten Lieblingsprotokolle. Nicht weil es besonders schön ist, aber weil alle irgendwie sagen, ja E-Mail und hier Google Wave und wir müssen irgendwie das alles besser machen, aber für wieviel fucking Jahre funktioniert E-Mail und ist mit dem Internet sozusagen wie viele andere Protokolle mitskaliert und ist einfach immer noch so...
Okay, und wie viel Prozent ist Internet-Traffic jetzt E-Mail-Spam?
Ja egal, aber nichts, dass du trotzdem skaliert mit, es ist dezentral.
Spam ist ein politisches und kein technisches Problem.
Spam skaliert mit.
Und du kriegst trotzdem noch Mails.
Und dieser ganze Ansatz, wie das ganze System aufgebaut ist, ich finde das immer noch sehr spannend. Als ich das erste Mal einen Mailserver aufgesetzt habe, ich habe ja schon viel aufgesetzt, einen Mailserver dachte ich, oh, okay, das ist wie Mail hinter den Kulissen funktioniert. Oh, so viel Perlcode wurde da verwendet, um das alles zusammenzukleben. Ach, interessant, guck mal an. Ja, oder was auch immer. Auch die ganzen Rappertools, die dir so ein bisschen zur Hand gehen, wenn du irgendwie einen Mailserver installierst und dann deine Paketliste anguckst, da ist Perl einfach in dieser Kette, da ist einfach so ein Batzen Perl mit drin. Auch so, wie das alles so aneinandergedübelt ist.
Du, jedes Mal wenn ich mir ein Exem neu kompiliere, sorge ich dafür, dass da ein Perl-Etappretter drin ist.
Als Nerd, da muss man das auch mal gesehen haben. Um so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie das, was man da die ganze Zeit benutzt, eigentlich so funktioniert. Das war auf jeden Fall ein Erkenntnisgewinn. Ich glaube beim ersten Messe war ich eine Woche lang dran gesessen, bis ich verstanden habe, wie das aneinandergestöpselt ist. Und bis ich verstanden habe, warum bestimmte Dinge so zu sein haben und wie man es konfiguriert. Und jetzt, als ich den neuen aufgesetzt habe, da ging das dann halt auch an einem Tag, weil erstens hatte ich diese eine harte, steile, vielleicht sogar rückwärts laufende Lernkurve vom ersten Mal schon intus sozusagen. Und dann konnte man halt auch so ein paar Configs abspicken und mussten sich nicht nur mit Tutorial-Cross- Referencing und Buchlesen helfen, sondern wusste schon, okay, das funktioniert.
Das Spannende dabei ist ja, dass so ein Ding relativ einfach aufsetzen kannst, dass du die ganzen Protokolle sprichst und irgendwas tut. Aber die Gefahr ist halt sehr hoch, dass du damit innerhalb weniger Stunden oder Tage im Internet auf die Nase fällst. Entweder weil du zugespammt wirst, oder weil andere Leute dich als Relay benutzen, oder, oder, oder, oder. Also sozusagen diese sekundären Kollateralschäden, die Nebenwirkungen, sind sozusagen relativ hoch.
Ja, es ist so wie heutzutage, du kannst einen DNS-Resolver aufsetzen, dann wirst du gleich hier für Amplification Attacks missbrauchen. Und wenn du in Mailserver das erste Mal so ganz naiv mal startest, dann bist du halt gleich auf einer Blacklist mit deiner Domain, weil irgendwie, what, du weißt nicht mal, was passiert ist. Und schon irgendwie sagen alle, du bist böse. Da kann man halt echt einiges an Spaß haben. Und das Ding ist natürlich auch, man liest halt irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwie so Tutorials und keine Ahnung, und die widersprechen sich natürlich auch alle gegenseitig. Und gerade bei Mailservern, wo so viele Komponenten mitspielen, da kann man sich einfach auch super auf die Nase legen. Und das Geile war auch, ich schreibe das auf Twitter, und dann glaub ich gar nicht, wie viele Leute gemeint haben, ja, hier gibt's eine Anleitung, Tutorial, machst du ein Video und so weiter. Und ich verstehe das ja. Ging mir ja auch so, als ich Mailservern und so.
Aber genau so macht man es halt eben nicht. Man muss sich da einmal durcharbeiten.
Ich bin irgendwie schon so ein bisschen der Meinung, man muss einmal auch da durchs Stahlbad so ein bisschen gehen und so seine Nasenspitze zumindest so ein bisschen aufschürfen. Weil sonst kopiert und pastet man halt irgendwelchen Kram zusammen, von dem man einfach nicht weiß, was es tut. Und es ist so, diese Mailserver-Config-Files, die sind ja auch kilometerlang mit Kommentaren und Optionen, wo man keine Ahnung hat, was die tun und die klingen gut.
Ah, ah, let's begin the war. Da fangen wir z.B. an. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum ich keinen Postfix benutze. Weil die Dokumentation dafür richtig, richtig, richtig stinkt.
Warte ganz kurz, bevor wir da den Flamewar starten. Aber es ist bei allen Komponenten so, du hast mit der Materie keine Ahnung voll gehabt. Du hast jetzt den Plan so, das erste Mal, ich setze mal Mailserver auf, du weißt nichts über die domain-spezifischen Terminologie usw. Und dann liest du so Sachen so, oh ja, das klingt gut, das ist bestimmt gut, gegen Spam anmach bedeutet, aber du kannst keine Mail mehr empfangen. Also jetzt mal so vereinbar gesagt, wenn man einfach nur so Copy und Paste irgendwelchen Schüssel da sich zusammen glaubt und am besten noch unterschiedliche Config-Teile von unterschiedlichen Tutorials, weil ja nie alle alles behandeln.
Und wo man dann feststellt, dass die Configs, die die da benutzen, dass die schon längst deprecated sind und da eigentlich voll neue Einträge gibt und wenn du mal Doku lesen würdest, also die natürlich viel zu groß ist für einen Anfang, aber wenn du es dann irgendwann dann doch mal tust, so spezifisch, dass du merkst, alles klar, eigentlich heißt das so und das heißt inzwischen so und wenn man es so macht, dann macht jetzt auch alles Sinn, weil das damals, wusste ich noch nicht, wie sie es nennen sollten also ich hab das auch letztes Jahr Mail Server aufgesetzt und kenne genau den ganzen Scheiß. Q-Mail?
Das wartet noch mit dem Flameball kurz.
Aber eigentlich gibt es ja gar keinen Flameball, weil wenn man es schon mal selber macht, dann ist man schon mal besser als, wenn man einfach Gmail benutzt, deswegen würde ich da gar keinen Flameball starten.
Was ich noch sagen wollte, zu diesem Thema hier, Tutorials und Anleitungen, deswegen, ich würde auch sagen, von allen Sachen, die man so auf seinem Server aufsetzen kann und will, und sowieso, Mailserver ist wirklich, ist so der End, also mit der Endgegner, würde ich sagen, weil wirklich alles andere, alles andere kann man sich schon relativ schnell mal durchlesen, so DNS geht schon irgendwie. Und Web-Server easy und so alles so, alles nicht so schwierig, aber Mailserver ist schon, da muss man einfach durch. Und dann sollte man auch nicht einfach seine Hauptdomain nehmen, wo man jetzt die ganze Zeit seine ganze Mail-Kommunikation drüber macht und so denken so, ja okay, Port 25 ist offen, alles klar, Domain umbiegen und passt schon und ab geht er. Wirklich, da muss man einfach, also ich würde sagen das erste Mal bestimmt eine Woche einfach sich so durch und mit Leuten sprechen, die es schon mal gemacht haben und fragen. Und deswegen liebe Hörer und die alle sagen hier auf dem Twitter, macht doch ein Tutorial und so weiter, ich kann euch gerne irgendwie ein paar Configs ins Gitter pasten, aber ich sage euch, das ist nicht der Weg, wie ihr ein Mailserver betreibt.
Richtig schlimm wird auch das erste große Major-Update, das war nach dem Installieren des Mailservers bei mir das fieseste, so nach zwei Jahren. Warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr? Und das Log war auch nicht hilfreich und im Endeffekt war das dann, man fängt wieder mit Trial and Error an, aber versucht irgendwie seine funktionierende Konfig krampfhaft nicht zu sehr kaputt zu machen.
Aber da muss ich auch sagen, nach dem ersten Mal Stahlball sozusagen und Nasenspitze aufschürfen, ist das jetzt alles beim so zweiten Mal, macht das alles mehr Sinn?
Man traut sich auch mehr, weil man weiß, man wird es wieder hinkriegen.
Genau, und so ein paar Probleme, die ich jetzt hatte, weil am Anfang natürlich hat jetzt auch nicht alles perfekt gleich funktioniert, so direkt beim ersten Starten natürlich, so irgendeine Konfig war immer noch nicht ganz in Ordnung, aber ich wusste schon, ah ja, ok, jetzt muss ich an den Teil dieses, dieser Pipeline, dieser riesigen Mail-Pipeline und da mal kurz stochern. So, also so viel zu diesem ganzen Tutorial, wie macht man das überhaupt wirklich, wie ich schon mehrfach gesagt habe, Trial, Error, Manual lesen, Leute fragen, Nase aufschürfen und dann geht's.
Und dann erst mal spielen, mit einer Spieldomain spielen.
So habe ich das übrigens auch mit dem neuen Mailserver gemacht, da habe ich auch irgendeine Domain, die ich noch rumliegen hatte, erstmal die genommen, den im X-Record gesetzt, um da das erstmal zum Wuppen zu kriegen. So, ja, jetzt die Frage, was benutze ich, also ich habe halt, als ich den ersten aufgesetzt habe, wie das halt auch, weiß nicht, war im Club, da war es ja auch so, alle haben FreeBSD benutzt, deswegen habe ich sowieso auch schon immer FreeBSD benutzt und irgendwie als ich im Club saß und den ersten Mailserver aufgesetzt habe, saß halt einer daneben, der einfach insgesamt sehr große Checkung hat und den wir auch alle kennen und schätzen und der meinte hier nimmer Postfix und dann habe ich Postfix genommen und das erschien mir so vom Gesamtkonzept durchaus sinnig, so wie das alles aufgebaut ist und so weiter. Ja, es hat eine elends lange und massive Config und die Doku ist da und sie ist in HTML plain und ungestylt, aber...
Lange Konfix haben sie alle, war schon seit Sendmail so und das ist schon über 20 Jahre her.
Aber an sich finde ich, also ich persönlich habe mit Postfix keine Probleme gehabt, ich habe allerdings auch nicht jetzt den Bedarf gehabt, andere auszuprobieren, kann sein, dass andere noch viel toller und schöner sind, aber Postfix tut, kann ich auf jeden Fall sagen, soweit. Und als E-Map-Server, da gibt es halt mittlerweile nur noch einen, der wirklich ernst zu nehmen ist, und das ist der DoveCut. Und der, muss ich sagen, ist auch in der Version 2 doch ein ganzes Stück eleganter geworden als die 1er-Version. Also, DoveCut, Postfix, Spam-Assassin mit dem unsäglichen Amavis-D. Ich habe schon überlegt, ob ich das auf Mildhör umstelle, aber das hatte ich irgendwie schmerzhaft in Erinnerung das letzte Mal.
Das ist ja auch ein Sendme-Konzept.
Und jetzt läuft das. Und dann haben gleich die Leute gefragt, ja, und hier machst du SPF und DKIM und DMARC und Dane und DNS-SEC und was es nicht noch alles so an Technologien gibt. Ich habe jetzt mal mit dem SPF-Rekord angefangen.
Allerdings nur einen im Text. Es gibt ja einen richtigen SPF-Rekord für DNS. Den nutzt deswegen kaum jemand, weil die alle ihr DNS irgendwo hosten und der Düsseliger DNS-Hoster, den ich kann.
SPF kann ich dir zeigen, habe ich gemacht, kenne ich alles.
Ja, habe ich ja jetzt auch.
Auf beiden Seiten.
Ja, checkt das auch und so. Aber das Problem für all diese anderen fancy Buswords, die jetzt danach kommen, also DKIM und DMARC und DNS-SEC und so, wenn man halt seine Domains, wie es in meinem Fall so ist, bei sowas wie Host Europe oder sonst irgendeinem Clicky Bunti Provider liegen hat, dann sind die Features da leider sehr limitiert und man muss halt im DNS ein bisschen rumspielen, um das halt einzubauen. Zum Beispiel, ich war es für DKIM, da muss man auch so ein Record mit Name Value irgendwie erzeugen und das geht zum Beispiel bei Host Europe auch schon nicht. Schon bei dem nächsten Schritt falle ich schon auf die Nase, wobei ich jetzt natürlich überlege, sollte ich jetzt vielleicht doch wieder auch meinen eigenen Name-Server betreiben?
Du gratigst ja dazu.
Ja, ich weiß ja. Der Nerd in mir sagt ja auch schon.
Nicht nur aus Nerd-Grunden, sondern das ist halt so, dass der Trend insgesamt auch von der Standardisierung dahin geht, die Security-Mechanismen, aktuelle Security-Mechanismen eben DNS zu verankern bzw. übers DNS zu verifizieren. Daher auch diese ganze Diskussion über DNS-Hack, weil wenn du jetzt security-relevante Sachen reinmachst, wie, weiß ich, irgendwelche Finger-Pins, zum Beispiel auch für SSH. Es gibt ja auch so ein SSH-FP-Rekord, wo du zum Beispiel auch deine SSH-Rost gießt, sozusagen nochmal verankern kannst. Damit das alles Spaß macht oder damit auch den Spaß macht, kann ich gleich nochmal vielleicht was zu sagen, diese ganzen Geschichten, da musst du natürlich dafür sorgen, dass niemand mehr an deiner DNS-Zone rumwächst und unertappt jedenfalls. Sie machen es natürlich trotzdem, aber dass es dann klar ist, da hat jemand dran gefingert, dass es oft dem nächsten End-User in Australien klar ist, der versucht, diesen DNS-Rekord zu benutzen, dass der jetzt gerade von irgendjemandem gefälscht wurde und nicht deiner ist. Das steht und fällt halt mit der ganzen DNS-Stack-Geschichte. Und wenn du das hast und das kriegst du derzeit nur, indem du sozusagen selber deine Zone hostest, das macht doch aus Security-Gründen nur Sünden, das selber zu hosten. Dann kannst du halt hingehen und kannst jede Menge lustige Zusatz-Records reinmachen, wie zum Beispiel das, was Tim ja schon lange immer gefordert hat oder immer wieder gerne haben möchte, diese Dane, wo man jetzt sagen kann, wo du sozusagen selber so eine Art Certificate-Pinning machen kannst. Wo du sagen kannst, meine Zertifikate dürfen nur von folgender CA ausgestellt worden sein. Oder hier nimm mein Zertifikat, so wie es ist. Scheißegal, wer es signiert hat, aber das ist mein Zertifikat, glaub dem mal. Da kommen wir vielleicht nachher nochmal dazu, zu dieser Let's Encrypt-Geschichte von Electronic Foundation. Also all diese Sachen, die da jetzt so kommen in dem ganzen Bereich, die basieren alle auf DNS-Einträgen und das kannst du mit diesen clicky-bunty-DNS-Hosts haben, wo du vielleicht ein A, ein Quad-A, ein Text und ein MX-Rekord reintun kannst, kannst du nicht machen, das geht nicht. Das heißt, und es ist am Ende des Tages, ist es auch gar nicht so schwer, wenn man sich jetzt das mal anguckt, ja, das war vor 5, 6 Jahren, war das eine tierische Fummelei, aber inzwischen kann man sich ein relativ schöne Setup aufbauen, was man sich einmal selber aufbaut, was dann auch sehr viele Updates eigentlich üblicherweise übersteht, wo man dann seine Änderungen nur noch dynamisch macht. Ich hab mir dazu mal so ein Set von Tools geschrieben, das steht da ebenso auf der Liste, nämlich meine DNS-Tools, und ich überlege, ob das mal mein erstes Git-Projekt wird, deswegen räume ich die gerade mal auf. Das ist halt so ein Tool, wo du aus der Kommandozeile einfach deine DNS-Records setzen kannst, beliebige, und was dir auch dabei hilft, bestimmte Sachen ausrechnen, was dir TLSR-Records ausrechnen, all sowas. Dass du jetzt nicht mehr Zonenfile editieren, SOA incrementieren, gegen den Primary-Gegentreten, bla bla bla, und diesen ganzen Scheiß, was man früher so gemacht hat, sondern dass du das alles als One-Stop-Shopping in so einem Ding da drin hast. Das ist einfach nur so ein Sammelsurium von Sachen, die ich da habe. Das kann man aber auch selber machen mit eingebauten Tools. Also heutzutage nochmal einen DNS-Server neu aufzusetzen, zu betreiben, ist echt kein Film.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Das habe ich ja in der Uni auch schon fleißig betrieben und mit Spaß gemacht. Nur für meine privaten Sachen, sagen wir nicht. Und hatte da jetzt auch noch nicht so den Bedarf direkt gehabt. Aber ja, jetzt wo ich sozusagen einmal die Sache in die Hand genommen habe, da könnte ich mal...
Gibt dir noch mal einen kleinen Setup-Tipp oder wenn du willst, gerne mal eine aktuelle Konfig, so als Konfig-Beispiel, die so ein bisschen abschweift von den 20 jahrten Tutorials mit named.conf, da, zonen-file, da und so, sondern, ne? Und dann wirst du sehen, das macht auch Spaß, wenn man das dann nämlich einmal am Laufen hat, hast du das eigentlich ganz schnuffig unter deinen Fetichen. Das ist dann übrigens sogar noch einfacher und schneller zu bedienen als die clicky-wunde Oberflächen von den Hostern.
Was sagst du denn zum Beispiel zu Power-DNS?
Power-DNS habe ich ein paar Mal gesehen, bei irgendwelchen Kunden mache ich es selber nicht. Also mein Zoo besteht aus Bind, für die Primaries und NSDs für einen Teil der Secondaries.
Weil ich glaube bei Power-DNS, da... Ist mir nicht bekannt eigentlich, aber...
Oder ist das das Tier von Bernstein oder was?
Nee, das ist ja dieses Tiny-DNS. Das ist ja total die Bankrotterklärung an Usability. Ja, nee, Power-DNS, das benutzen ein paar Nerds auf jeden Fall und das hat halt auch so ein bisschen mehr Clicky und ein bisschen mehr Bunty. Aber auch Features. Also da geht, glaube ich, den...
Da guck ich gerne mal drauf.
Da geht DNS-Tag, glaube ich, auch mit, wenn ich das recht in Erinnerung hab.
Gen tut das eigentlich mit allen. Die Frage ist, wer macht ja die Krypto? Wer signiert dir das? Macht das Ding für dich? Oder musst du selber einmal die Zonen-File befummeln und da ein Tool drüber laufen lassen, was dir die RSEC-Records da reinschmiert und so? Das ist halt die Frage, wie das geht. Mit einem modernen Bind geht das halt so. Da sagst du, hier ist mein Zonen-File, da ist mein Key-File. Viel Spaß. Das heißt, diese ganze Signaturgeschichte macht das Ding alles von alleine. Und die Secondaries interessiert das eh nicht. Die importieren die ganze, komplett signierte Zone vom Primary und das heißt, da kannst du für die Secondaries wieder irgendwas einsetzen und auch irgendwen. Ich hatte dir das ja auch geschrieben, wenn du da was basteln willst, ich biete dir gerne auch Secondarieservice an. Ansonsten kann ich auch mal wieder auf meine Freunde von HiEnet verweisen, die wir ja schon kennen für die LPV6-Tunnel, für die coolen. Die bieten auch Free-DNS-Service an und auch eben auch Free-Secondarieservice. Das heißt, denen sagst du einfach, wo dein Primary ist und erlaubst du auf dein Primary, dass die deine Zone ziehen dürfen und dann hast du das auch drauf. Und die haben es schön verteilt, Anycast aber quer über die ganze Welt. Also das wuppt auch ganz gut.
Was bei PowerDNS ganz schnuffig ist, da kannst du halt Videos von den clicky-bunti-Hostern kennenzulernen, wenn du jetzt für deine Freunde noch DNS-Hostes denen halt Accounts geben, wo sie nur ihre Domains zum Beispiel verarbeiten können.
Kann ich auf dem Band auch.
Ja, aber das PowerDNS kommt halt gleich mit dem Interface daher.
Ja, die können da einfach klicken und dann sagst du hier, der Huckel darf huckel.de und dann kann der da alles klicken.
Die Frage ist, wie weit sind die, was aktuelle DNS-Standards angeht? Kann ich da mehr als ein A und ein Quad-A-Record und ein Text-Record reintun?
Die PowerDNS-Jungs sind schon vorne dabei, würde ich sagen.
Das heißt, ihr glaubt denen schon, dass der Server das kann, aber dass auch die ganzen Benutzer vielleicht nicht so was. Ich guck es mir mal an, ich finde es ja immer interessant. Ich betreibe ja sechs Name-Server insgesamt, die ich verteilt habe auf der Welt und ich habe nichts dagegen, jetzt noch einen dritten Typ mit reinzunehmen. Statt jetzt nur NSD.
Also sie sagen zum Beispiel auf ihrer Webseite die PowerDNS-Authoritative-Server hat ca. 90% der DNS-Domäne in Europa, mit über 1 Million DNS-Domänen in den Niederlanden alleine.
So, mal noch mehr Themen, sonst artet es aus hier mit euch.
Ich wollte dir noch zwei Sachen mitgeben zu deinem Ding, was ich zum Beispiel nochmal, du nutzt auch Roundcube als Webmailer.
Die haben ja noch vergessen, die Komponente.
Wir hatten ja schon vor etlichen Freak Shows mal über TOTP berichtet, was manche Leute Google Authenticator nennen, diese App, die dann immer schön 6-stellige Zahlen generiert, alle 30 Sekunden. Da gibts eine sehr schöne Plug-In für Roundcube, was dir das erlaubt. Optional kann jeder User für sich selber an- oder ausknipsen. Und wenn man jetzt gerade überlegt, wann benutzt man ein Webmail, wenn man gerade eben nicht an seinem eigenen Rechner ist. Und da wird es jetzt vielleicht nicht dein normale Mail-Passwort eintippern notwendigerweise. Ich meine, du musst immer noch eintippern, aber gerade für so ein Webmail-Ding ist es sozusagen ein ganz netter Add-on. Die haben allerdings einen Flaw drin, den ich ein bisschen unverzeihlich finde. Die generieren den QR-Code nicht selber für das Secret, sondern die benutzen einen Google-Webservice dafür. Denkst du auch so, hm, ja klar. Hallo Google, hier ist ein Secret, machen wir mal ein QR-Code draus.
Was mir bei der Recherche übrigens jetzt noch so, also ich habe Google natürlich jetzt auch da im Rahmen dieser Mail-Server-Geschichte ganz viel umher, da hat mir dann auch einer, ich packe es mal hier gleich in den Chat, kommt das da? Ein Chat scrollt ja noch mit. Ach, du bist im Show Notes-Channel hier irgendwie abgebogen. Rain Loop ist irgendwie auch so ein Webmail-Interface, was jetzt irgendwie relativ frisch ist, was damit wirbt, auch gleich PGP und alles im Web-Interface irgendwie damit zu integrieren und alles ganz modern und toll. Allerdings, als ich mir das jetzt so angeguckt habe, auch auf GitHub und wer da so committet und so, hatte ich jetzt so den Eindruck, das scheint jetzt auch noch nicht so das allerabgehangenste zu sein und noch im Flux sich zu befinden. Aber war auf jeden Fall mal, wenn man eine Alternative noch zu dem Roundcube mal sucht, wobei ich jetzt erstmal nicht so einen Grund hätte, kann man sich dieses Rainloop auf jeden Fall auch mal anschauen, weil die zumindest sagen, okay, wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie mal so ein leichtgewichtiges snazzy and fancy Webinterface mit auch Krypto-Features und was man nicht noch so alles haben will.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das der andere schon kann, aber Rainloop kann halt auch sehr schön Multi-Accounts. Ich hab das irgendwie gegen meine eigenen Server und dann noch den Gmail-Account wegen dem Telefon und was weiß ich nicht alles. Und das kommt da so schön alles in einem mit Single Sign-On. Das klappt echt gut.
Ach so, das Roundcube ist eher so, du hast einen IMAP-Server und dafür einen Frontend.
Du darfst auch mehrere haben. Du kannst mehrere Server haben und du kannst auch ansagen, dass der User seinen eigenen Server da haben kann, seinen eigenen Server eingeben kann. Auch beliebige IMAP-Server, das kannst du machen mit Roundcube. Und noch ein Add-on, wenn du noch mal kurz auf die Liste da gehst. Es gibt, ist ja gerade für die Apple-User, Apple nimmt sich ja das Recht heraus, selbst bei so gut abgehangenen Standards wie Mail, wieder mal ein eigenes Süppchen zu kochen. Nämlich, sie benutzen nicht das IMAP-IDLE-Commando. Ich kann die Gründe auch nachvollziehen, das ist natürlich trotzdem albern. Das heißt, so ein Apple-Mobilgerät, jetzt nicht die Mac-Server. Ein Apple-Mail auf einem Mac kann IDLE. Mobilgeräte, iPhone, iPad, können das nicht. Sondern die pollen halt Mail. IMAP-IDLE ist dafür da, dass du sozusagen die Verbindung zum Mailzauber aufrecht erhältst. Und selbst wenn du jetzt gerade nichts machst, in den Mailzauber sagst du, ich mach jetzt übrigens nichts, ich bleibe aber jetzt sozusagen mal hier online. Wenn eine neue Mail kommt, sag mir mal Bescheid. Das heißt, dass du die nicht dauernd immer pollen musst, sondern du schießt sozusagen, du klappst sozusagen für einen Moment mal dieses Server-Client-Relationship um, wenn du so willst. Das heißt, dass du sagst, ich höre dich, ich warte, hallo Mailzauber, ich hab jetzt selber nichts zu tun, sag mir mal Bescheid, wenn sich bei dir was tut. Also jetzt nicht nur neue Mailzauber, sondern auch andere Sachen. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich eine relativ schöne Geschichte, um halt eben zeitnah deine E-Mail auch zu bekommen. Apple macht das selber natürlich basierend auf Apple Push. Also da kann jetzt Roddy eher mal was dazu sagen, aber benutzt dieselbe Infrastruktur, die auch Applikationen benutzen, um sozusagen was aufgenommen zu husten. Aber nicht mehr in Deutschland, weil sie da irgendein Patent-Ding verloren haben. Ja, sie haben Motorola und Geld in die Hand gedrückt, und jetzt seitdem machen sie das wieder seit einem halben Jahr oder so. Nichtsdestotrotz, Apple benutzt ja selber auf ihrem OSX-Server und der kann das, der kann diesen Apple Push für Mail, hat aber einen Dove-Code drin und gibt also jetzt Leute, die sich mal angeguckt haben, wie sie das gemacht haben. Und Apple selber macht das so, dass sie einen Plug-In gebaut haben für DoveCode, der ist sogar irgendwo mal wieder veröffentlicht, da wo sie auch ihren komischen, das ist so andere Zeugssachen. Ja, sowas haben. Das hat aber jetzt ein Typ nicht nachgehackt, weil das benutzt noch andere Apple-Komponenten, sondern der hat sich das aber genauer angeguckt. Und es gibt jemand, der hat sozusagen nochmal ein Plug-In geschrieben für DoveCode, was ohne Apple-Komponenten auskommt, Software-Komponenten, was allerdings immer noch, damit das nämlich mit dem Push funktioniert, so ein Push-Zertifikat braucht. Das ist allerdings relativ einfach zu erlangen, weil da gehst du nämlich einfach hin auf irgendeinen OS X-Server und klickst einfach, ich hätte gerne mal ein Zertifikat. Und dann holt dir sich ein Zertifikat und speichert das in deiner Keychain, da kannst du das raus extrahieren und dann kannst du das für deinen eigenen Push benutzen. Das wollte ich, wie gesagt, nochmal hinterherwerfen.
Möchtest du noch einen Chat schubsen, damit das auch in den Show rauslernen?
Ich bin nicht im Chat, kannst du das mal da oben klauen und dann mal rüberkopieren bitte?
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, also Connection halten auf einem mobilen Gerät ist aber auch nur so eine mittlere Idee. Weil da musst du natürlich Radio anlassen und solche Sachen.
Das macht das Push-Zeug ja am Ende des Tages auch. Aber die Problematik ist eine andere. Die Connection halten tut dir ja nicht weh, weil du normalerweise transportierst keine Pakete. Das Problem ist, dass es andere Leute gibt, die dir das übel nehmen, dass du keine Pakete transportierst. Nämlich zum Beispiel die Mobilnetze, die ja in der Regel NUT einsetzen. Da ist so eine Carrier-Grad-NUT-Solution da, die sieht, oh hier ist eine TCP-Session, aha, markiere ich mir doch mal, und dann, oh, seit fünf Minuten kein Paket mehr gesehen. Na, die wird wohl nicht mehr existieren. Und das heißt, die bricht ja diese TCP-Connection immer kaputt. Und alle möglichen NUT-Devices, Firewalls machen das und so weiter und fort. Also, das ganze V4-Internet mit deiner NUT und Firewall-Scheiße ist so verseucht, dass du da keine nicht ungestraft bestehenden TCP-Sessions nicht benutzen darfst. Und wenn du sie wieder benutzt, dann kostest du wieder Batterie oder Geld.
Ja, dann kannst du auch die Verbindung gleich wieder zumachen.
Gut, wie dem auch sei. Also, es ist, wie gesagt, es gibt übrigens auch, es ist schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren auch in der Standardisierung für iMap gibt es auch Leute, die sich befassen, wer danach mal googeln will, es sind sogenannte Lemonade Extensions. Leute, die sich überlegt haben, wie kann man das besser machen, gerade für mobile Geräte oder so. Man kann ja diese ganzen Mail-Protokolle auch verbessern. Da gibt es denn solche Features. Ich glaube, die nutzt ein iPhone sogar. Ein iPhone nutzt teilweise die. Du kannst, wenn dein Server das unterstützt, kannst du zum Beispiel, wenn du Mails vorwartest, musst du sie nicht erst auf dein Gerät runterladen, für lange Dauer und viel Geld kostet, und sie dann wieder weg zu senden, sondern du kannst sozusagen direkt deinem IMAP-Server sagen, diese Mail, dieses Attachment aus dieser Mail oder diese Teile, diese Elemente, schickst du mal bitte per SMTP irgendwohin. Also übergibt die mal an den SMTP-Server und schickt die mal irgendwohin. Also solche Sachen. Und diese Feature, glaube ich, nutzt iPhone sogar. Muss ich noch mal nachgucken, ob das immer noch so ist, aber ich glaube, ich habe das mal dabei erwischt. Nö, Forward. Also eigentlich bei allen möglichen Sachen, wo du sozusagen selber hingehst, eine Mail zusammenkomponierst aus Bestandteilen anderer Mails. Zum Beispiel beim Forward nimmst du die komplette andere Mail. Du kannst aber zum Beispiel nur ein Attachment nehmen oder nur bestimmte andere Teile. Dann liegen die auf Serverseite beide vorhand. Also du sagst, ich komponiere hier was und da packst du aber jetzt bitte das aus der IMAP Message 4711, das dritte Attachment packst du jetzt mal bitte damit rein. Das ist heller kompliziert, die Syntax- herfür ist auch total gruselig und so was. Aber es gibt diese Extensions, gibt es schon eine ganze Weile auch und ich habe glaube ich das iPhone mal dabei erwischt, dass es sowas macht. Ich müsste es jetzt mal ausprobieren, interessiert mich jetzt auch gerade mal. Also da geht noch was, wollte ich nur sagen. Und die Leute, die so richtig kaputt sind, können übrigens auch folgendes machen, die können übrigens noch so ein X, wie nennt es sich, so ein Active Direct, nein nicht Active Director, wie heißt es denn? Active, diese Microsoft-Zoll? Active Sync, genau. Es gibt ja so auch frei verfügbare Active Sync-Server, Seiten oder sowas, die mit einem iMac-Backend arbeiten, zum Beispiel auch diese Zimbra oder sowas, oder nee Z-Tools, keine aus Berlin glaube ich, so eine Bude, die das macht. Die kannst du dir auf deinen Apache noch draufschmeißen oder auf deinen Engine X. Der spricht dir nach vorne Active X zu deinem Telefon, so richtig schön Microsoft-ig, mit große Otschaf. Und nach hinten raus spricht der SMTP und iMap. Geht aber. Ja, riecht ein bisschen nach Lulu, geht aber. Damit kriegst du auch diese ganze Push-Thematik hin und noch so ein paar Späßchen.
Ja, das Schöne ist ja an meinem Mesh-Server, ich habe gar keine Microsoft User, ich habe gar keine... Was soll dich selber? Ich habe noch ein, zwei Freunde, aber da weiß ich, die sind... Die sind clean. Die sind clean. Die wissen auch, was Sache ist und was eigener Mesh-Server bedeutet und so weiter und so fort. Also da gibt es keine Debatten und keine Diskussionen und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen, das ist halt... Wir hatten ja mal hier in der Freak Show, hatten wir ja mal über dieses Mail-Thema gesprochen und Huckel-Mail. Und dann haben mich ja irgendwie alle Leute auf Twitter gefragt, wann gibt es denn jetzt hier Huckel-Mail und könnte man da mitmachen? Weil ich hatte ja immer gefragt, ob Leute für so ein Mail-Service Geld ausgeben würden. Und daraus haben erst mal alle geschlossen, dass ich vielleicht vorhaben könnte, das so anzubieten. Ich habe auch drüber nachgedacht tatsächlich, aber das habe ich wieder verworfen. Weil ich habe keine Lust drauf, so einen ganzen User zu im Zaum zu halten. Und das ist Freunde von, also auch Leute aus dem CCC, die machen das schon seit eh und je. Die haben so einen Mail-Server und da ist es auch für einen erweiterten Freundeskreis.
Ich habe auch Friends and Family drauf.
Und was die mir dann halt so erzählen, mit was für Problemen die da, also da haben die sich halt einen, also auch so einen Hacker-Freund da mit auf den Server geholt und der ist einfach so ein Spam-Magnet. Also der hat irgendwie zig Domains, zig Accounts und irgendwie eine Zeit lang war einfach 90% des Mail-Server-Traffics sein. Shit der die ganze Zeit irgendwie.
Das ist doch die Story, die ich vor ein paar Monaten erzählt habe, wo das ZFS mit einer Million Files vollgelaufen ist.
Der macht halt auch schon Mail seit immer, seit er wahrscheinlich das erste IP-Paket empfangen hat.
Der ist schon lange dabei.
Ja und irgendwie, das ist so der Schmelzpunkt für jeden Mailserver, der Schmelztest. Auf jeden Fall, ich hör die ja, oder als ich immer noch viel im Club saß, hab ich die auch immer so, als sie das alles aufgesetzt haben. Und dann, als ich meine Planung für den Mailserver gemacht hab, da hatte ich auch so, eigentlich, nee.
Ausgesuchte User.
Ausgesuchte User, wo man weiß irgendwie, und vor allem, ich will auch gar nicht erst anfangen mit Quotas, hab ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf und so.
Ich geb dir einen guten Grund, weil manchmal hast du solche Runaways. Du kannst ja die Quotas beliebig hochsetzen, aber du solltest nicht keine drauf haben. Weil manchmal hast du einfach Mail-Schleifen, für die weder du noch dein User, noch sonst in jemanden was kann. Und bei den heutigen Speeds, gerade wenn du eine gehustete Maschine hast, die ratzt dir so schnell voll. Das ist einfach blöd. Mach ne Quota rein auf 100G. Irgendetwas kleineres als dein Fallsystem, ist scheißegal, aber mach die Quotas an. Jetzt nicht um deinen User zu malträtieren, du bist ja nicht 1 und 1. Wenn dann dein User seine 100G voll hat, dann machst du das letzte Ding auf 200G. Irgendetwas kleineres als dein Fallsystem, damit du das Ding nicht ganz abratzt bei der nächsten Mail-Schleife. Das passiert sehr schnell.
Zumindest in den 6,5 Jahren in dem Uni-Setup hatte ich noch keine Mail-Schleife, aber ich denke mal drüber nach.
Vielleicht war dein Spam-Erkennung gut genug dafür.
Zumindest habe ich keinen Bock drauf, wir haben jetzt so viele Platten platz, und dann kriegt ihr jetzt so einen Slice. Nee, Mail und Fail, nicht drüber nachdenken. Das soll wuppen. Und deswegen, so Multi-User-mäßig usw. Macht das lieber selber. Wir hatten ja auch in der Sendung ein paar Mail-Anbieter, die das Host mal genannt, wo man schon mal weg von Gmail kommen könnte. Aber naja, es geht uns alle was an, aber man muss sich auch jeder selber mit dem Thema mal intensiv auseinandersetzen. Oder eben noch nicht, bei Gmail sein und alles ist gut. Und damit schließt man jetzt auch dieses Mail-Thema einfach erstmal ab. Es gibt halt einfach so viele Leute, mit denen ich da so drüber über dieses Mail-Thema gesprochen hab und die dann halt anfangen so, ja, aber wieso denn nicht einfach bei Gmail? Also ich könnte mich jetzt eine Stunde lang mit dir unterhalten. Vielleicht auch nur eine halbe Stunde, aber ich hab eigentlich überhaupt...
Ja, geh doch zu Gmail. Wieso eigentlich Mail? Nützt doch dein Facebook, das reicht dir doch.
Weißt du, was viel schlimmer ist, wenn man den Leuten sagt, ey, hör mal zu, ich hab hier einen Mail-Server, der ist voll toll, du musst dich bei Gmail gehen, du kannst zu mir kommen, dann finden die das verdächtig, weil man denen ja was anbietet, wo die dann ihre privaten Daten überschicken und dann wollen sie nicht. Oder? Dann bleiben sie lieber bei Google, weil bei Google sitzt dann irgendein Typ, den sie nicht kennen, der mitlesen könnte, aber ich soll halt deren Sachen nicht mitlesen und ehrlich gesagt, ich versteh das sogar, weil man will nicht, dass Leute, die man kennt, irgendwie den eigenen Scheiß mitlesen, aber wenigstens wenn die Fremde das machen, dann ist es egal.
Hast du so wenig Vertrauen in deinem Freundeskreis?
Ne, die in mir.
Ja eben, also die vertrauen dir so wenig, ja?
Ja, wie viele Leute hast du überzeugen können auf deinem Netzwerber?
Ich musste gar keinen überzeugen, also die...
Normale freiwillig?
Ein weiteres Problem ist ja dieses, was ist, wenn was schief geht, so deine Nerdfreunde backupen vielleicht noch ihre Mails, die anderen aber nicht.
Wenn die sauer auf Gmail sind, ist das nicht dein Problem, aber wenn dir die Platte abgeranzt ist oder die ihr nicht erhalten, weil es irgendwie im Spam-Filter hängen bleibt, dann sind die halt auf dich sauer.
Oh ja, aber goldene Regel beim Spam-Filter ist auch so. Spam-Filter, Grundsatz, Diskussionen, wobei, ja, ich glaube, wir sind da alle eigentlich wahrscheinlich einer Meinung, dass man Spam jetzt nicht wegschmeißt, aber...
Packen aber nicht wegschmeißen.
Man sortiert ja auch nicht weg. Also meine Policy ist, wenn es mir zu spammi aussieht, geht es zurück an den Absender. Das heißt, ich lehne es ab, ich lehne es richtig ab, schon auf SMTP-Ebene. Also ich nehme es nicht erst an und versuche es dann wieder zurückzuschicken, sondern ich lehne es gleich ab beim Eingehen. Oder ich stelle zu, das gibt bei mir keinen Spam-Folder, weil das gibt immer Ärger.
Genau, damit jeder User das halt so selber filtern kann, wie er es gerne haben will.
Das hat sich jetzt so gut eingenordet im Laufe der letzten Jahre. Ich betreibe ja mein Ding insgesamt schon über 20 Jahre. Klar, die Spam-Filter sind schon relativ neu, dann auch mit ihrem Tuning und sowas. Aber ich lebe dann mit den paar Spam-Dingern, die ich so kriege am Tag mal ein oder alle zwei Tage mal ein.
Ich mache die header-Anime rein für den Spam-Checker, und dann kann jeder User sich das selber aussuchen. Entweder ich zum Beispiel mache es mit Manage Thief, mache mir halt so einen Filter, wenn jetzt irgendwie Spam gleich Yes ist, dann bitte in den Ordner wegsortieren, aber bei die Folge kriegt ihr halt erstmal in die Inbox und kann sich selber aussuchen, aber im kleinen Filter.
Können meine User auch, macht aber keiner von denen aus.
Genau, ich habe es halt meinen 5 Hanseln mal gesagt, und das funktioniert. Aber das Schlimmste ist eigentlich, wenn man eine gehostete Mail hat, und die dann einfach irgendwelche Mail wegschmeißen, im schlimmsten Fall nicht mal Bescheid gesagt haben, und du dann einfach nur so da sitzt.
Das ist im Übrigen in Deutschland sogar illegal, richtig?
Ja, ich glaube, das macht auch keiner mehr, aber am Anfang, früher gab es halt sowas irgendwie.
Es gibt echt Leute, die schon erfolgreich gegen andere Nasen geklagt haben, weil deren Spam-Filter was so wegsortiert hat, was definitiv Spam war, die aber trotzdem gesagt haben, hallo, das ist Unterdrückung von Post. Das ist ein Straftatbestand.
Das ist auch richtig geil. Früher habe ich ja Zeitungen ausgetragen, um mal mein erstes Taschengeld zu verdienen. Und ich meine diese Wurstblätter daher, das ist ja wirklich null Inhalt. Das ist nur hier Fleisch, morgen ein Hackfleisch gemischt, 1,90 im Supermarkt. Und irgendwann fährt man halt so, es regnet, es kalt und denkt sich so, ja, die Straße da hinten... .trage ich jetzt mal nicht aus. Aber dann beschweren sich halt auch Leute richtig massiv, weil sie den Spam nicht gekriegt haben. Das verstehe ich auch. Ich verstehe nicht warum, aber dieses Unterschlagen von...
Ich kenne auch Häuser, wo du die ganzen Briefkästen siehst und auf allen drauf steht, keine Werbung, bitte. Und auf einem oder zwei stehen drauf, Werbung, ja, bitte.
Echt?
Sind denn die Omas, die eh...
Aber die Schilder liest doch eh keiner mehr. Mein Schild macht genau keinen Unterschied. Ich habe noch nie was nicht bekommen, weil da das Schild steht, glaube ich. Aber es gibt einen Aufteiler, der sortiert die Zeitung nicht mal ein, sondern er schmeißt einfach den ganzen 10er-, 20er-Stape in den Papierkorb. Wenn man das haben will, kann man sich das da wieder rausziehen. Also, wir haben so einen Papierkorb direkt nur für Papier, für Postkasten und so. Und einer macht gleich, ach, warum soll ich die da 20 mal reinschenken?
Dauert für den Landwirt gleich so rein. Ein gemeinsames Spendraum für das ganze Haus.
Ich glaube, ich werde meinen Schild auch ändern, von bitte keine Werbung in, ich schmeiß die in den Papierkorb, der da so 50 cm unter meinem Briefkasten ist.
Und vielleicht lernen sie es ja dann.
Geht auch schneller, als du durch den Schlitz reinkummeln.
Du machst es so, du machst ein Foto von diesem Papierkorb unten, klebst dieses Foto auf deinem Briefkasten und schreibst dann rauf so, hier, bitte Werbung, Pfeil auf das Foto da rein.
Oder sollen sie es da auf so eine Ablage legen und jeder nimmt sich seinen Ding da weg, aber dann, ich will es nicht jedes Mal aus meinem Papierkorb fischen müssen. Schon gar nicht diese dicken Zeitungen da, die man da kaum rausspielt.
Liebe Werbeausträger, die jetzt gerade Freak Show auf ihren Ohren beim Werbeaustragen hören. Bitte immer ins Papier-Ablagefach unter den Briefgästen.
Und nicht vom Fahrrad fallen.
Da müsste man sowieso alles verbieten.
Dafür werden sie aber nicht bezahlt, ne?
Na, wir werden sowieso nicht mehr richtig bezahlt, ne?
Ich will, dass Roddy noch über ZFS erzählt.
Ja, Roddy, du hast irgendwie heute noch gar nicht den Mund so richtig aufbekommen. Die ganze Zeit nur ein Bier trinken.
Ja, daran könnte es auch liegen. Ich habe so ein E-Book aufgetrieben, das heißt FreeBSD Mastery Storage Essentials. Und das ist relativ interessant. Das erklärt mal die gesamten Zusammenhänge, wie das eigentlich mit den Disks und den Devices und diesem Ganzen, wo man halt so Daten drauf machen kann unter FreeBSD, wie das alles zusammenhängt mit irgendwelchen Device Geometry Providern und dieses ganze Zeug. Also ich habe das Ding noch nicht besonders weit gelesen. Was mir schon aufgefallen ist, ist, dass er gerne über Legacy-Technologien spricht. Sowas wie Master Boot Record Partitioning Scheme und so ein Scheiß.
Das ist ziemlich Legacy.
Ja, und auch dieses alte File-System von ZFS. Wie heißt das doch gleich?
Nicht von ZFS, von FreeBSD.
Das ist halt UFS, was halt nicht ZFS ist. Also darüber scheint er sich gerne auszulassen.
Das ist auch der Urvater von vielen dieser Dinger. Das gibt es ja auch schon ewig.
Ja, aber ich denke, da kann man schon mal reingucken. Das kostet irgendwie so 10 Dollar. Man kann auf der einen Webseite das irgendwie in allen Formaten kaufen für 10 Dollar. Ich war dann aber zu faul und hab's mir doch im iBook-Store geklickt. Ja, aber irgendwie, bevor ich jetzt da anfange, da mit PayPal rumzumachen und so weiter.
Ja, dann kriegt der Auto einfach mal viel mehr Geld. Ist doch voll asozial bei iBook zu kaufen.
Im iBook-Store 15 Dollar gekostet oder so.
Nee, im iBook-Store hat es dann halt die 9,99 Euro gekostet. Okay, beim derzeitigen Umtauschkurs kriegt er wahrscheinlich trotzdem weniger. Ja, dann soll er hier nicht mit PayPal und so. Das ist mir zu schuld. Ja, das ist egal. Also ich meine, kann ja jeder kaufen, wo er es will. Also wie gesagt, ich war halt zu faul.
Roddy, ich tadele dich im Interesse der freien Autoren, die ihr Geld verlagstfrei verdienen wollen. Und wenn sie schon einen alternativen Bylink ohne DRM und ohne allen Pipapolen in allen Formaten anbieten, dann würde ich das auf jeden Fall immer vorziehen. Also als so eine Content-Sandbox, aber das ist nur meine Meinung.
Nee, das war noch nicht über ZFS. Aber das erklärt mal so ein paar Grundlagen. Über ZFS, ja, weiß ich gar nicht. Also es gab irgendwie gerade eben eine neue Release-Kandidate von MakeZFS.
Ja, mitten in der Sendung muss ich natürlich auch gleich installieren. Hat sich so ein bisschen was geändert, aber das ist nicht so das Spannende. Das Spannende ist das andere.
Dieses dem Weiß-Removal-Ding anstatt. Und zwar, du hattest da irgendwie so einen Tweet retweeted, der aber irgendwie auch schon 26 Tage alt war.
Ja, der war irgendwie vom letzten Jahr, aber ist irgendwie untergegangen. Jedenfalls haben die Open-ZFS-Jungs den noch mal retweeted gestern, und dann habe ich den auch noch mal retweeted. Und da ging es um, ja, was war es? Die Weiß-Removal.
Die Weiß-Removal.
Ich habe es nicht genau durchgelesen, aber du hast gesagt, du hast diesen Vortrag gelesen.
Naja, ich habe den Vortrag, also ich habe ihn überhaupt erst mal auf YouTube gefunden und habe da ungefähr 30 Sekunden reingehört und dachte mir, du hast doch da noch so einen Auphonic-Account. Du musst das jetzt erst mal durch Auphonic jagen. Vorher kann man es ja gar nicht verstehen. Und dann habe ich also das YouTube-Video, habe ich mir mit YouTube.dl einen Streamcache angelegt. Und diesen Streamcache mal nach Auphonic getan. Und als der von Auphonic wieder zurückkam, konnte man immerhin ein bisschen was verstehen. Also ich weiß nicht, warum die ihre Talks da aufzeichnen. Also weder das Audio noch das Video ist irgendwie brauchbar. Also man sieht die Slides nicht, man versteht die Leute nicht, die da sprechen, aber naja, nachdem Auphonic da einmal drüber ist, war es immerhin so ein bisschen verständlich. Der Mensch hat darüber geredet, wie sie jetzt endlich das mal machen wollen, dass sie da Devices aus einem Pool rausnehmen. Und zwar, das Problem ist ja prinzipiell, wenn man so ein Multi-Device-Pool hat, dass irgendwelche Block-Pointer auf irgendwelchen Devices irgendwelche Blöcke referenzieren.
Also das Problem ist eigentlich, dass wenn du ein Mirror anlegen willst und du nutzt nicht Append, sondern Ed, oder andersrum, weil ich weiß es auch immer nicht, anstelle von einem Mirror entsteht plötzlich so ein Raid-0-Stripe. Dann hast du halt die Arschkarte, weil das hat das dir eigentlich gar nicht vor. Und du kriegst das Stripe da auch nicht wieder weg. Das heißt, du kannst deinen ganzen Pool neu machen, obwohl du eigentlich nur ganz simpel eine weitere Platte rankleben wolltest. Und dann hast du voll die Arschkarte. Und mit diesem Device-Removal müsste man diese Operation, weil auf der neuen Platte ist ja noch gar nichts rüberkopiert, die wird ja nicht sofort durch das Stripe neu verteilt, eigentlich ist sie ja noch komplett leer, müsste es sogar relativ easy und schnell gehen, die da auch wieder wegzukriegen. Und ich nehme an, das ist das, was uns dieses Feature bringen will und das ist schon ein großer Fortschritt, weil ich glaube, ganz viele Leute machen das bald.
Man sagt, dem räumen wir alles, was auf dieser Platte drauf ist, frei. Das heißt, du solltest natürlich auf den anderen Platten in Summe so viel Platz haben, wie die, die du frei räumen willst.
Genau, was bei uns bei der Ergebnis, weil du hast ja gerade erst angefangen.
Aber dass du dann sagst, mach mal das Ding sauber, sodass man es jetzt ohne Geschrei einfach mal abstecken kann.
Na, der würde dann sagen, hier kann ich nicht, weil ist nicht genug Platz, das wird ja wohl alles raussitzen.
Aber wenn, dann soll er das alles zusammen raffeln, sozusagen, ich sag jetzt mal Garbage Collection auf der Platte, wir schieben das mal alles zusammen und defragmentieren mal.
Moment, nein, nein, nein, wir kommen zu den Details, die sind nämlich ganz interessant. Wie du das unter ZFS normalerweise machen würdest, ist, du würdest alle Blöcke rumkopieren, du würdest alle Block-Pointer, die auf diese Blöcke zeigen, umschreiben. Turns out, wie man so schön sagt, stellt sich heraus, das ist einfach nicht machbar, weil das einfach viel zu viel Aufwand ist. Und jetzt haben die sich überlegt, okay, wir führen so eine Art Mapping ein und sagen, okay, der Bereich von hier bis da auf der einen Platte kopiere ich jetzt komplett auf die andere Platte und sage alle Block-Pointer, die in diesen Bereich pointen vorher, werden jetzt umgebogen auf den anderen Bereich, auf die andere Platte. So haben die das jetzt vor. Und ob das, naja, ob das dann ordentlich funktioniert? Sie haben wohl noch so ein paar ungelöste Probleme.
Das ist kompliziert, weil ich glaube, sie wollen es ja so, dass wenn die Operation, also wenn dein ZFS mittendrin abkackt und er bootet neu, dass man danach halt locker damit weitermachen kann. Deswegen ist es halt nicht so einfach. Die können das nicht einfach in einem Rutsch machen, sondern es muss ja auch resetfest sein, so wie ein Scrub auch weitermacht, nachdem halt ein Reset passiert ist. Der merkt sich seine Stelle, wo er schon gewesen ist und fährt dann fort. Und Scrub, glaube ich, beruht auf dem, dass die, die haben den Scrub irgendwann umgebaut und das war schon auch in Hinsicht auf dieses Block-Pointer-Rewrite irgendwie, dass sie da den Baum so langfahren und ja, die Blöcke oder die Pointer der Blöcke umschreiben.
Ja, wenn ich ihn richtig verstanden habe, meinte er, dass es auf jeden Fall sinnvoll wäre, wenn man das Feature macht, dass man vorher einen Scrub macht und erst dann dieses Device Removal versucht.
Vielleicht musste ich das Feature noch ein bisschen setteln und irgendwie abstauben und so weiter ein bisschen.
Also angeblich haben sie schon Code in irgendeinem dieser Branches drin. Ich weiß nicht, ob es der Illumos...
Nee, der Delphi-Tipp hat das ja gepostet.
Ja, aber in welchem ZFS?
Na, von Delphi, nicht von Illumos.
Delphix, oder wie das heißt?
Ja, genau.
Naja, die meinten auf jeden Fall, sie hätten relativ viele Kunden, die halt irgendwie...
Ja, das will man auf jeden Fall haben. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob es auch für einen Ray-Z funktioniert, weil auch da wäre es eigentlich cool. Aber wenn man Stripe schon nach irgendwie zwei, drei Jahren die kleinste Platte da mal wieder abkapseln kann, um eine neue dran zu kleben, das wäre schon super cool. Weil das geht nämlich nicht. Deswegen bin ich eigentlich immer Fan von Mirrors, weil bei Mirrors kannst du das irgendwie easy den Mirror wegmachen, durch eine größere Platte ersetzen und so. Wobei in Stripe kann man eigentlich auch ein Replace mit einer größeren Platte machen. Ja, wenn du es ganz weghaben willst, dann brauchst du halt dieses Feature. Wie auch immer, das war ZFS. Mehr gibt es ja da eigentlich auch gar nicht, ne?
Wir kommen schon langsam ans Ende der Sendung, oder?
Definitiv.
Weil ich bin total durch. Und wir haben ja jetzt sozusagen eine 1,5 Stunden schon gesendet auf dem Kongress.
Dat heißt, es ist jetzt ja nicht 149, es ist jetzt 148,5.
Also, ok, pass auf, dann den Abschlusskanon leite ich ein. Mit erstens sage ich noch, den Vortrag, den ich irgendwie, in den ich morgens reingestrampelt bin und überraschenderweise positiv total begeistert war, war from, oh Gott, jetzt bekriege ich es zusammen, dieser Artificial Intelligence Talk, wie hieß der denn? Ja, zu Computation, irgendwie hörte er auch, from irgendwas, ah nee, from Computation to Consciousness. Den fand ich sehr schön, erstens, weil das war nicht so ein Typ, der irgendwas rausgefunden hat oder einen Studienarbeit gemacht hat und einfach mal so daher geblabbelt hat, sondern der ist, also da hatte ich gleich so nach den ersten paar Slides schon den Eindruck, okay, der ist richtig in diesem Thema drin, also so richtig umfänglich. Der ist auch vom MIT irgendwie, oder arbeitet da. Und auch bei den Fragen hat man das hinterher gemerkt, da kamen dann so ein paar Leute ans Mikro und haben ihm so ein paar Buzzwords irgendwie aus der Szene an den Kopf geworfen, um mal zu gucken, so ist er fit und der hat die dann halt auch gleich so richtig am Schopfer gepackt und mal von allen Seiten beleuchtet, ihre Pseudo-Argumente, oder Argumente. Fand ich wirklich einen sehr schönen, interessanten Talk, auch sehr eingänglich für Leute, die mit AI und so weiter einfach noch gar nichts zu tun hatten oder sich mit Hirn und Computern und so in dem Sinne nicht auseinandergesetzt haben. Sehr guter Talk. Und zweitens wollte ich noch sagen, auf dem Kongress, ich meine, wir sind schon immer auf dem Kongress, und wir machen auch die Freak Show oder Mobile Max schon seit ein paar Jahren. Und eigentlich gab es schon immer die Gelegenheit, uns da zu treffen. Also es ist nie so, dass es ein großes Geheimnis wäre, dass wir da sind oder es gibt auch Avatar-Bilder von uns und so. Es gab schon immer die Gelegenheit. Aber? Aber dieses Jahr war anders, weil diesmal kamen tatsächlich ganz viele Hörer vorbei. Also nicht nur durch diese Freak Show vermutlich, haben auch schon viele im Vorfeld auf Twitter gefragt und an Tag zwei oder drei mussten sie sich zugetragen haben, dass um zwei Uhr nachmittags, also 14 Uhr, der erste schrub, sag mal Huckel hier, wo bist denn du? Ich würde dir mal ein Bier ausgeben. Und ich war in der Lounge und habe mir ein Bier ausgeben lassen. Kam auch, wenig später schon der zweite, hatte ich zwei Bier in der Hand und das ging bis morgens um drei oder vier weiter. Und ich war schrub...
Selbst ich bin in der Lounge über Leute gestolpert, die sich...
Und war insgesamt auf jeden Fall sehr putzig, ist immer wieder komisch, also auch bei dieser Live-Show, so weil man dann die Hörer halt mal sieht. Und wenn wir dann komisch gucken oder ich komisch gucke oder irgendwie alles so ein bisschen so... Realitätsabgleich ist, ja, also versteht es nicht falsch. Es ist halt einfach komisch, wenn man hier die ganze Zeit in einer kleinen Runde sitzt, sich so gegenseitig irgendwas ins Ohr labert und plötzlich stellt man fest, da sind es Leute, die hören das und finden das auch. Und an dieser Stelle nochmal Dank an alle, die irgendwie mit Bier und anderen spenden, irgendwie auf dem Kongress.
Von mir auch.
Von mir auch. Besonders an die Freak Show Ultras, die mir ein Bier ausgegeben haben.
Die Freak Show Ultras.
Nur dir? Nur mir.
Das heißt, du weißt jetzt auch, wer es ist?
Die Freak Show Ultras ziehen es vor, dass das nicht bekannt ist. Und ich entspreche dem natürlich.
Das ist eine Geheimorganisation.
Auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, war schön, euch da zu treffen und mal ein Bier mit euch zu heben oder in eine Tüte zu rauchen. Nächstes Jahr gerne wieder oder beim nächsten Mal oder Camp einfach auch gerne wieder. Aber es war trotzdem dieser, weißt du noch, als wir bei dieser kleinen Erlangen-Konferenz waren und so ein Typ kam, ich hoffe du hörst jetzt nicht zu und fühlst dich feierhohne piepelt, aber es war ein bisschen komisch, der von uns ein Autogramm haben wollte und da, da war ich wirklich echt so total so What? Warum? Wieso? Was machst du damit? Und dann hat er gesagt, es ist nicht für mich, es ist für einen Freund.
Willst du zumindest Freundin sagen?
Du meintest doch, dass du eigentlich auch mal gerne eine Livesendung machen würdest mit Zuhörern?
Klar.
Aber ich glaube, auf so einer Veranstaltung bist du eigentlich viel cooler, oder?
Ja, wobei ich durchaus auch Potenzial sehe, dass wir dann mal so eine separate Veranstaltung draus machen können, nur das ist halt Arbeit.
Was willst du denn da belabern? Ich meine, auf dem Kongress haben wir über den Kongress gelabert. Wenn wir eins auf dem Camp machen, können wir auch über das Camp reden und so. Aber bei so einer Live-Anstaltung über normal wieder 12 Zoll Mac-1-Diggins zu reden?
Da ist schon immer was eingefallen.
Klar, aber ist das dann auch gut?
Dennis, da lassen wir dann einfach zwei Sendungen vorher aus und dann haben wir noch...
Da haben wir eine große Bühne, da könnte ich sagen.
Da muss man sich halt was einfallen lassen. Das kommt bestimmt total gut an.
Wir lesen Mailserver Configs vor. Und die Kommentare über den Configs-Parameter. In feinstem sauer Crowd English.
Okay, Roddy, dein Lieblingsvortrag noch? Nachdem er jetzt eingeplackt ist. Ich will jetzt auch noch einplacken, aber du sitzt zwischen mir und Hucke.
Ich hab jetzt keinen Lieblingsvortrag. Ich wollte noch mal sagen, dass ich es auch sehr schön fand, die ganzen Hörer, weil ich hab mich mit vielen auch länger unterhalten, unter anderem so einem Flugzeug-Nerd, mit dem konnte ich natürlich so ein bisschen auch über alte Cargolifter-Zeiten plaudern. Hab ich ja auch mal ein bisschen Flugzeug gemacht. Nee, fand ich sehr schön. Aber ich plack keinen Vortrag.
Du hast doch irgendjemanden gesehen haben, der dir gefallen hat.
Ja, hab ich, aber ich hab zu wenig gesehen, als dass ich da jetzt bin.
Irgendeiner, der nicht sackt.
Pfff, NordNews-Show sackt nicht. Obwohl, die waren ein bisschen depressiv dieses Jahr. Also dieses Mal, das ist ja schon letztes Jahr.
Das ist leider...
Das ist ja auch wie die beiden Opas aus der Muppet Show.
Von allen. Und noch ein Kandidat für den Sendungstitel. Ich bin durch Zufall auf einen draufgetreten, weil der, wie viele dieser Titel von diesen Vorträgen unglaublich daneben liegen.
Was übrigens daran liegt, dass es eine weitere Unsitte, die sich auf dem Kongress eingeschlichen hat, was ich ja persönlich absolut für einen Fehler halte. Es gibt so einen Trend, es gibt uns auch einen Trend, der sich bei Chaos Radio immer wieder eintritt, wo ich jahrelang gegen gekämpft habe, aber mittlerweile habe ich da ja keine Karten mehr. Die Titel werden immer zu etwas, was eigentlich unter Titel ist. Das heißt, die Titel sind immer so total so, was weiß ich, irgendwie... Da müsste man ja schon, dass es schon um DNS-Sack geht. Das ist irgendwie eher so was, wie ich den Fisch im Garten fing und dabei irgendwie erleuchtet wurde.
Und es müsste eigentlich heißen Angeln.
Genau. Nee, das müsste wahrscheinlich heißen Hardcore-Mail-Server-Konfiguration. Das ist das, worum es eigentlich geht, aber das steht dann im Untertitel. Das hat sich so ein bisschen eingeschlichen. Das heißt, die Titel versagen einfach da drin, ihre eigentliche Kernaufgabe zu erfüllen. Mit dem Scheißteil einfach einen Titel zu geben. Und der muss nicht lustig sein. Lustig, dafür gibt es Untertitel und überhaupt. Man kann es vielleicht auch lustig machen und trotzdem sagen, worum es geht. Naja, ich bin dagegen.
Also in meinem Fall war der offizielle Titel Let's Encrypt. Und das klang wieder so wie diese jährliche Gejammer, was der CCC bei jeder Veranstaltung immer und überall abgibt. Die Leute sollen doch bitte mehr verschlüsseln und lalalala und VIPAPO. Enthältet auch. Aber, womit da wirklich geht, ist, dass sich jetzt mal Leute hingesetzt haben und gesagt, warum machen so wenig Leute Verschlüsselung an, auf ihrem Server zum Beispiel, weil das Beschaffen dieser Zertifikate immer noch ein teures und aufwendiges fucking pain in the ass ist. Und die Leute, die dahinter stecken, hinter diesem Projekt dort, die Electronic Frontier Foundation, also eff.org, habt ihr bestimmt auch schon mal gelesen oder gehört, also schon Netzpolitiker der alten Schule, die jetzt einfach hingehen und sagen, pass mal auf, damit es jetzt einfach wird, machen wir jetzt A, mal eine CA selber auf, die hoffentlich in allen Browsern und so weiter auch verankert ist, die einfach mal diese Dinger für umme raushaut. Also jetzt nicht hier für da ein Geld oder da, oder jedes Jahr neu bezahlen, sondern die einfach A, Zertifikate für nix raustut. Und B, sie haben so ein Toolset auch dabei, das hat der Typ da auch so ein bisschen vorgestellt, das ist derzeit nur für den Apachen. Damit selbst die dümmsten Admins das geregelt kriegen, ihr Ding umzustellen, das ist total krass.
Die dümmsten Admins.
Das ist wirklich echt krass. Die haben so ein Tool, das guckt sich deine Apachen-Konfig an, was du alles für virtuelle Server konfiguriert hast, mit den Domain-Namen, generiert automatisch Zertifikate mit Private Keys, schubst die über eine API in dieses Ding da rein, lässt sich die signieren, holt die zurück, baut die in deine Konfig mit ein und startet deine Apachen durch. So, One-Stop-Shopping, einfach nur, mach mal HTTPS an, return, fünf Sekunden später, pfff, dann. Mit Zertifikat und Soße und Scharf.
Ja, aber wie wollen die denn in den Browser kommen mit ihrer CA?
Guck dir doch den Vortrag da an, der erzählt es schon. Ich muss das jetzt nicht...
Ob ihr auf CAZ jetzt irgendwie schon seit wieviel Jahren?
Guck dir den Vortrag an.
Ich glaube, CAZ hat aber weniger Funding wahrscheinlich als die EFF.
Sie haben Kooperation. Erstens machen sie selber gerade eine Zertifikation für ihr Laden, dass sie den Spielregeln dieser Browser-Community dort, die ja sagen, wer hier CA sein darf und wer nicht, entsprechen. Dass sie sich dort dann auditen lassen von denen. Das ist gerade wohl in der Macher. Außerdem haben sie aber einen Kooperationspartner, der schon drin ist, der ihnen ihre Dinge unterschreibt. Bis jetzt nicht mehr aus dem Kopf, wer das ist. Aber guck dir den Vortrag an. Das fand ich durchaus mal ganz interessant. Es ist ja in aller Munde. Außerdem war jetzt wieder Jahresende und ich nutze normalerweise immer die Zeit zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, um meinen ganzen Zertifikatskram auf Vordermann zu bringen. Und diesen ganzen Krypto-Quatsch und Software-Updates. Das passt jetzt ganz gut. Ist jetzt noch nicht aktiv, aber in Kürze. Aber der Vortrag ist interessant. Der Typ spricht auch ganz nett.
Das kann man sich auch gerne mal so anhören.
Gut.
Peter?
Gleichzeitig, Saal 1 bis 4.
Eigentlich habe ich glaube ich erst 3 oder 4 gesehen, aber welchen ich ganz gut fand, das war ja kein technischer Talk, war von Stefan Wehmeier, IFG. Stefan. Genau, geht es um dieses Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Und ich fand ihn deswegen ganz spannend, weil irgendwie als Nerd hat man das irgendwie so wahrgenommen. Wir haben jetzt dieses Freiheitsgesetz und da wird schon jemand irgendwie Anfragen stellen, aber weiter habe ich mich damit halt auch nicht befasst. Und das war mal jetzt so über die ersten 2 Jahre, glaube ich, so ein ganz netter Rückblick, was das eigentlich bedeutet, dass man da jetzt irgendwie an Medien rankommt, an Informationen rankommt. Und der hat es eigentlich ziemlich souverän vorgetragen. Also lohnt sich auf jeden Fall mal reinzugucken, was da so erreicht wurde.
Ja, Stefan ist nicht nur sehr aktiv in diesem Projekt, ja schon seit vielen Jahren, sondern auch einer derjenigen, die sein Anliegen auch gekonnt rüberbringen können. Dennis, du hast noch keinen Top-Nerven. Keinen einzigen?
Ja, plack doch einfach jemanden, den du kennst.
Was ist denn derjenige, von dem du denkst, dass du ihn dir als erstes anschauen müsstest, weil dir so viele Leute gesagt haben?
Den von Tobias und den von Starbucks.
Der ist der Sieben-Dinger.
Ich kenne ja den Tobias und ich habe die Geschichte schon vorher ein bisschen gehört, aber als er mir davon erzählt hatte, da ging es noch nicht um Abhören, da ging es nur noch um Lokalisieren. Irgendwann im Herbst war das. Und dann auf einmal dachte ich, was ist denn jetzt daran so spannend? Und dann meinte er, jetzt kann man noch ein bisschen mehr machen als nur Lokalisieren.
Also im Prinzip die Bankreuterklärung dieses SS7-Systems. Nicht weniger als das. Ich muss mir auch nochmal anschauen, ich hab so Teile verpasst, aber im Wesentlichen ist es alles ganz furchtbar und kaputt. Dieses ganze SS7. Was, falls jemand nicht weiß, was es ist, das Protokoll ist, was halt die ganzen Telcos untereinander sprechen.
Das ist ICMP des GSM, könnte man das so nennen?
Nö, das ist IP des Telefonnetzwerks.
IP sogar?
Jaja, das ist das Protokoll, mit dem alle Telefonnetze miteinander sprechen.
Der Protokollstack, die haben ja auch so eigene Dinge da drauf, verschiedene Protokolle da drauf. Und er bezieht sich hier zum Beispiel auf MAP, auf den Teil dem Mobile Application Part.
Ja, ich wollte eine Erklärung liefern, die den Leuten die Dimensionen...
Ich muss jetzt nur diese Idee mit dem ICMP da wieder rückrollen, das geht mir jetzt nicht.
Ja, der Vortrag von Starbucks, der war ja auch nun extrem in the News. Ich sehe, also bin ich du. Und da hat er unter anderem gezeigt, wie man einfach von Fotografien Fingerabdrücke rekonstruieren kann.
Und Ihres Dinger, oder?
Die Bundesregierung hat doch schon dementiert, dass das geht.
Es besteht zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine Gefahr.
Haben sie es auch für beendet erklärt?
Haben sie es schon pofallert?
Das wolltest du vertrauen.
Wir haben jetzt einfach die erste Sitzreihe in der Bundespressekonferenz abmontiert. In der Hoffnung, dass das reicht.
Ich hab da auch schon so einen schönen Photoshop mit Frau Merkel mit so Fingerhüten auf den Finger.
Braucht die doch nicht. Braucht doch Frau Merkel nicht.
Vielleicht verpixeln sie sie auch einfach.
Vergausen.
Pixeln. Ich weiß, dass es gausen ist, aber fixeln klingt besser.
Feierabend. Winke, winke. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Genau. Wir reden irgendwie über den Rest. Ich bin total durch.
Tim war heute beim Sport.
Nee, aber heute woanders.
Ich bin jeden Tag beim Sport. Wie auch immer. Wir machen hier mal das Ende. Leiten wir schon mal ein hier.
Wir bedanken uns bei Peter, dass er da war.
Genau. Danke Peter für die Einblicke ins Vok und drumherum. Ja, das war's. 148. Sendung der Freak Show.
Wir sagen Tschüss. 147,5.
Wie lang war eigentlich die Sendung im Kongress? Stunde 20, echt?
Passt schon.